[Music]
you have no right to infringe the basic
human rights of everyone even the
criminal with the infliction of torture
so if you say God has said we should
amputate the hand of the thief that is a
clear example of how certain commands in
Islam are against human rights and
therefore not compatible with modern
human rights thinking and I stand in
front of everyone today with full
confidence that this claim will not be
refuted liberalism can and has and is
capable of producing death penalty
outcomes for non-religious to the state
for example a dude
the laws barbaric outdated dysfunctional
laws which is a genetic fallacy by the
way and you should know as a philosopher
that presents in cases like this is weak
then he mentioned democracy which is
even look is even older than Muhammad so
it's even more outdated so it should be
even more wrong in your understanding
but then here's what I'm saying to you
the point is this bismillah
alhamdulillah
what salat wa salam o allah rasool allah
i welcome all of you with islamic greet
greetings
assalamu aleikum wa rahmatullah wa
barakato may the peace blessings and
mercy of allah spirit allah be upon all
of you I am
Fahad Qureshi the chair for this debate
today this very interesting debate about
Islam does Islam need to be liberalized
or not and we are talking specifically
about traditional Islam Orthodox Islam
and by liberalized we mean do we need to
renew Islam is Islam
suitable for the 21st century is Islam
suitable for the West and the values
that we are living within in the West
that's the main topic of discussion
today why is this topic so important the
reason why it is so important is that
politics are based upon this we see
different political suggestions coming
all the time wanting to change Islam or
restrict Islamic practices based upon
the notion that Islam is not suitable or
traditional Islam is not suitable for
the modern Western society Islam needs
to be liberated it needs to be
progressed in terms of being able to fit
in the modern context so that's going to
be our debate today and the organization
organizing this debate is as you know
Islam net and Islam net is a Norwegian
Dawa organization focusing upon giving
Dawa meaning spreading information about
Islam in the Western society with a
special focus on Norway and we also we
also have a big focus on inspiring young
Muslims to find their Muslim identity
and feel confident about their religion
so inspire young Muslims to come back to
allah subhanaw taala and one of our main
projects nowadays is that we are raising
funds to establish a norwegian Dawa
center and a mastiff a mustard and a
Dawa center that we hope that would help
the Muslim Norwegian youth reconnect
with allah subhanaw taala because as we
see the masses of young muslims they may
not be practicing islam they may not be
very interested in Islam but if we
reconnect their faith with Allah then we
believe that that would be bringing them
success in this world and in the
hereafter so if you want to know more
about this project who name this
projects save a man so you could go to
the website save a man dot-com and read
more about it save a man calm and for
those watching online we will have the
link in the description to read about
that project for you to be able to
support that project as well this is a
man she's 14 years old a norwegian
muslim living with her parents in the
next 20 seconds she is going to send
indecent pictures of herself to her
secret boyfriend this is why Norway a
Scandinavian country that Muslims
migrated 250 years ago with around two
hundred thousand Muslims but this is
changing Muslim names are increasing but
Eman is dying in the hearts of our youth
the vast majority of these Muslims do
not pray and are leaving their Islamic
heritage and adopting the western
lifestyle why is this happening why are
the youth leaving the Islamic way of
life the majority of Muslims came to
Norway seeking financial opportunities
the mosques that were established were
centered around culture from back home
and the next generation of Muslims
assimilated to the western lifestyle the
main source of Islamic knowledge
remained the Friday sermon that was
conducted in the mother tongue of the
first generation of Muslims so the youth
didn't connect to it a man is not happy
at home her parents often tell her to
start praying and stay away from boys
and that makes he-man feel suffocated
and depressed because no one taught her
why islam teaches Muslims to pray or why
it sets moral boundaries for
relationships with the opposite gender
a man doesn't know what to do on one
side she loves her family and she loves
Allah on the other side she doesn't
understand Islam and its restrictions
and guidelines don't make sense to her
so she is living a double life Muslim at
home and someone else outside a man is
not just an individual she symbolizes
the Eman of the majority of young
Norwegian Muslims they are struggling to
retain there is
identity and are drifting away from
Islam we need to save a man we need to
start at the grassroots level the
problem lies in a lack of Islamic
knowledge resulting in the weakening of
Eman so we want to build the country's
first Islamic Dawa Center combined with
a Masjid that will share the message of
Islam in a way that the youth of today
can relate to it will have a Youth
Center where the youth can come instead
of hanging in the streets or going to
Western clubs it will have Islamic
programs and activities where the youth
can learn their religion it will have a
studio for mass production of Dawa
material for social media it will
educate the Muslim community on how to
bring up their children on Islamic
values we have already raised about 1
million dollars locally and to make this
project come true we need to raise the
remaining amount there are 1.8 billion
Muslims but the question is are you one
of those very special people who will
help save Eman please click the link
give for the sake of Allah and earn your
reward also we need to make the Muslim
world aware of this campaign so please
do whatever you can share this video on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and all other
social media networks we alone cannot
save you man
but together we can
[Music]
so back to the debate our two very
respectable candidates for the debate
today are dr. large Lula and Mohammad
Haeju so to begin with let me introduce
dr. large Lula who will be the first
person to speak today dr. large doula is
a philosopher he has graduated with a
doctorate in philosophy and is an
associate professor at Oslo
metropolitian
University from 2002 the year of 2005 he
was secretary-general of the Norwegian
humanist association goona became famous
or known to the general public in 1977
when after having joined the DF LP group
gula was arrested in Beirut Lebanon with
explosives in his luggage intended for
Israeli targets leading to a six-month
conviction and subsequent deportation he
remains a pro palestinian a pro
palestinian and in regards to his stance
on islam and muslims my personal opinion
is that he is very balanced he is very
honest he is not the kind of person who
would spread fabrications about islam
and muslims he is not the kind of person
who would spread Islamophobic theories
in fact he is one of the most outspoken
individuals in a norwegian context
against right-wing extremists and people
who spread the conspiracy theories about
Islam and Muslims so we have great
respect for dr. Lodge Allah in spite of
disagreeing with him in some some points
and he is a critic of Islam and on my on
my left hand side is Muhammed job he is
a
famous debater and youtuber he is well
known from his debates from a Hyde Park
at speakers corner where he debates many
different people and he travels around
the world and engages in dialogue in
debates with academics so Muhammad hijab
is very well known in the in the Muslim
world and he completed a degree in
politics and a master's in history from
Queen Mary University he completed
another master's degree in Islamic
studies at the School of Oriental and
African Studies he has taught and
instructed courses on humanities and
languages in many contexts he has
numerous ideas in some Islamic Sciences
and has studied in multiple Islamic
seminaries including the champagne
Institute which employs a traditional
Mauritania style of teaching the sacred
sciences Mohammed is currently doing
further postgraduate studies in applied
theology so that's our two respective
speakers for tonight's debate and the
setup will be that each speaker will
have 20 minutes to make his case to make
an introduction to his case so we will
start with dr. Lodge Bueller giving his
presentation and then Mohammed hijab
will give his presentation in 20 minutes
each after that we will have ten minutes
each of a rebuttal session where dr.
Nash will be responding to what Muhammad
hijab has said and vice versa
after that we will have a
cross-examination where each of the
speakers would have the opportunity to
cross-examine to ask questions to the
other speaker and that speaker would
have three minutes each to answer those
specific questions after that we will
have our we will open the floor for the
audience so the audience could all
to participate and ask their questions
to each respective speaker and we will
conclude with each speaker having five
minutes to give their final statements
so without any further ado I would
request dr. Lodge to take come to the
microphone and begin his presentation
thank you thank you very much for the
invitation and I believe it is fruitful
to have serious discussions thank you
about these important questions and the
question posed today is thus traditional
Islam need to be liberalized the answer
is yes and I could actually stop here
and give the remainder of my time to my
honorable opponent because he will need
more than the allotted he's allotted 20
minutes to explain why his outdated and
dysfunctional religious tradition does
not need liberalisation in the 21st
century however for this to become a
meaningful debate I will give some of
the reasons for my short answer but
first of all there are internal
resources in the Islamic tradition in
traditional Islam that can be utilized
and that has been utilized in the past
to develop interpretations that take
Islam in a liberalizing direction
especially the interpretive principles
of HD had supplemented with the
principle of the common good Messala
furthermore my short answer of course
has to do with how we understand the
term and the concept traditional Islam
what is it what is this object that I
and many with me including numerous
Muslims think things are in need of
liberalisation
we also need to clarify what is meant by
liberal say
is it the same as reform or affirmation
it seems that what it seems that Islam
net organizing this event have made this
interpretation the most relevant for
this debate but I'm not sure that it is
but my honourable opponents views on
Islam and traditional Islam are not the
only views he and his followers attempts
at monopolizing their interpretation as
the correct interpretation or mainstream
interpretation of Islam flies in the
face of the fact that their position the
position of Islam net and the followers
of Islam net here today is a minority
position within the Islamic world today
it's not the majority it is not what
Muslims nor not even the majority of
scholars think is the right
interpretation so before I give my
reasons for why reform of Islam should
entail liberalisation I will say
something about this what is Islam and
so-called traditional Islam part of the
problem is that it is almost impossible
to give an all comprehensive definition
of Islam it is a religion in that sense
it is what Muslims believe within some
parameters one cannot say I'm a Muslim
and believe anything there are a certain
limits but those limits are fairly wide
Islam is even more it can be said to be
a culture and also a 14th centuries old
civilization and these three forms Islam
as religion Islam as a culture and Islam
as a civilization or these three ways of
understanding Islam will overlap and
they influence each other here we are
concerned with Islam as a religion and a
religion can be said to consist of the
following factors or elements
a cosmogony that is a narrative of
creation a story a story about how
everything came to be a cosmology and
understanding of how the world is
working and epistemology an explanation
of how we know what we know and ethic
rules for a good life
and finally cultic practices the short
Islamic answers to these points are on
the cosmic journey God Allah created the
world out of nothing
cosmology God has organized the world
and is the cause of everything that
happens perhaps in certainly
interpretations and we see how variation
in the interpretation enters very
quickly into the picture
some think that perhaps science can help
us understand how God had organized the
universe the universe ie everything
epistemology a theory of knowledge
saying that we have knowledge through
revelation perhaps science can help us
understand but revelation is the most
important source of knowledge ethics the
rules for a good life are the same as
the will of God for mankind or the
revealed law of God Sharia and Sharia
covers all aspects all aspects of man's
life especially or actually not only
between all men then WOM a lot but it
also covers when we come to cultic
practices man's relation to God Emma dot
which is also part of the overall legal
ethical perspective of Islam so of
course there has been differences in the
understanding of these building blocks
of Islam throughout is
history some have said that the world is
not created but eternal coextensive with
God
others say that man has free will and
therefore man can cause both good and
evil there are those who have said that
the revelation is as found in the Quran
and Sunnah cannot be understood
literally we need to understand the
metaphoric language of the Quran and
even the hidden meaning of the Quran and
interpret it in a rational way others
say we should take the word literally
and not try to understand the metaphors
of the Quran as God is sitting but he is
totally different from human beings how
can he sit below keifa others say that
we should take the word literally and
not try to understand while Sufis say we
should attempt union with God and they
have areas medet of techniques developed
for the purpose and perhaps the Sufi
traditions the two Sufi tariqas are the
largest organisations of Muslims in the
Muslim world
many Muslims mix traditional values and
Islam and still believe they are good
Muslims ie they are following the will
of God some find ethical guidelines in
what they believe is the will of God as
revealed in the Quran and the example of
their prophet but the will of God even
if seen by many Muslim scholars as
complete and total system needs
interpretation based on Quran Sunnah HT
had an edge man however there is no
unanimity on how to interpret
accordingly there are many
interpretations with major and major may
major differences in Sunni Islam there
are four surviving schools of law mada
him but there have been other attempts
at understanding the will of God those
schools so those attempts did not
survive the test of time and we have
numerous other differences in
metaphysical approaches in theological
approaches etc there are differences
that vary over time and there are
differences from place to place within
the Muslim world in the past and today
enjoyed our numerous versions of Islam
even within Sunni Islam and in addition
we have various Shia interpretations do
they all have something in common apart
from the five pillars difficult to say
as an outsider as a researcher it is not
my job to decide which interpretation is
the correct one
that's for Muslims to quarrel about
you're welcome
and I do mr. hijab has no serious claim
to represents the to the true
interpretation as a researcher I observe
that there are certain agreements on the
level of scholars and also certain
elements practical in a practical Islam
so to speak common practices across
various interpretations and cultures
some of these interpretations and
practices do need to change for example
the discrimination of knowledge
discarding scientific knowledge that
goes against revelation discriminating
internally within Islam against those
you disagree with like for example the
Shia at Medea but also within Sunni
Islam the MARTA Silla not respected not
accepted as part of traditional Islam
today furthermore the discrimination of
women needs to be changed as we can see
here today with the women relegated to
the back that sort of segregation is not
good for anyone and if you say well
we're separate but equal there is no
example in history of separate but equal
that's what the apartheid supporters
said in South Africa there was no
equality between blacks and whites
segregating men and women makes one
sexes oppressed compared to the other we
see it in the strict demands on women's
women concerning their clothing and
their behavior and in regulating their
education and choice of professions
which is something that Islam that has
attempted to do by giving advice on what
studies are suitable for women what
professions are suitable for women in
Norway there is discrimination of
non-believers on equal rights according
to interpretations of Islam unacceptable
you have the discrimination of sexual
minorities with the emphasis in certain
circumstances of the death penalty but
in practice in most countries social
exclusion chase them away they are not
part of us anymore we don't want to have
anything to do with them the change of
these attitudes and practices should
most move Muslims in the direction of
greater freedom and equality freedom and
equality for all that is what I would
call liberalisation when I advocate
liberalisation of Islam I am NOT talking
about replacing Islam with political
liberalism that's a different matter
that would mean abolishing Islam and
establishing political philosophy of a
certain kind as a substitute religion if
that would be possible at all I am
talking about the verb the process then
to libera liberalized means according to
dictionaries to make something search us
a law or a political or religious system
less strict or to make or become liber
then what is liberal or someone who is
liberal not necessarily some someone who
embraces the political philosophy of
liberalism again according to a
dictionary a liberal
is someone willing to understand and
respect other people's behavior opinions
etc especially when they are different
from your own believing people should be
able to choose how they behave or
wanting to or wanting or allowing a lot
of political economic freedom and
supporting gradual social political or
religious change that are reasonable
definitions of a liberal person and
liberalizing processes our movement in
that direction these processes and
attitudes are or should be compatible
with various interpretations of Islam
the theological resources for
interpretation in such a liberal and
therefore liberalizing direction are
there in Islam the interpretive
principle of each D hat can be used and
supplemented with the principle of the
common good Muslim as resources for
interpretive change however currently it
is narrow and confining interpretations
that have the theological and
ideological hegemony in the Muslim world
thus each D hat is often limited to
Kia's analogical reasoning and not used
in an innovative and progressive as an
innovative and progressive principle
which could in union with mass llaha be
the basis for a more dynamic
understanding of the Sharia and
therefore make Islam more compatible
with the modern world including modern
science and human rights but and this is
important it is for Muslims to decide
how they want to live this is a right
according to modern and liberal values
ie human rights it is a basic human
right you have the right to decide for
yourself nevertheless because it is
possible to make these changes I hope
and I argue for a process of
liberalisation that is based on
recognition of the
human dignity and worth of every human
being a process that accepts the best
instruments we have to protect every
human beings dignity namely human rights
and a lot and the logical attachment to
you equal human dignity and human rights
is democracy
thus interpretations of Islam that
embrace equal human dignity human rights
and democratic political organization of
states and societies is what I would say
represents much-needed liberalization of
traditional Islam and if the
liberalization of Islam in its various
interpretations today including the
so-called traditional interpretations
were steered by a free and liberal
practice of each DeHart inspired by
masla ha we would see a gradual
reduction in the segregation of the
sexes great the tolerance for
differences within the Muslim community
acceptance of non-believers including
marriage marriages across religions
freedom of religion and the right to
change religion without social sanctions
freedom of religion for children
acceptance of sexual minorities respect
for fully freedom of expression and
acceptance of what some might see as
blasphemy acceptance of critique of
Islam of course with the right to a
vigorous defense hopefully based on
reason an important part of this process
of liberalisation
is based on freedom of religion for
everyone thus those Muslims who want to
live their lives in different ways in
stricter ways are absolutely allowed to
do so nevertheless they have to accept
the rights of others to criticize their
interpretations and their ways of living
and conservative traditional or strict
Muslims should not try to force other
Muslims to change to their ways of
living they can use persuasion because
also the strict conservative traditional
or so-called true Muslims
are free to use their freedom of
religion and freedom of expression to
influence others this is exactly why we
need to respect the rights of others
Muslims and non-muslims to live their
lives as they wish
thank you thank you dr. lush for your
presentation so we will now have the
introduction of Muhammad hijab so you
may come to the podium please so Ari
come welcome to live all together can
you guys hear me this is a bit low
should I bring up a bit is this better
is it better or is it mm all right well
thank you very much dr. Gould for your
presentation it was a bit more moderate
than your previous presentations I must
admit with other debates I've seen of
yours so I appreciate the more nuance
that you put into the discussion let's
start with definitions because I think
this is a point of difference actually
between me and gule gule a good I said
that the definitions that he took were
from dictionaries vernacular definitions
or dictionary definitions are invariably
influenced by ideological ones and so I
would put to him that dictionary
definitions are actually influenced by
political and social outcomes around
around those particular definitions when
they're being written in order to avoid
such bias one has to go before the 16th
century for example when liberalism was
around and find definitions then that
would be I think an appropriate recourse
for someone who wants to use a
dictionary finition however I would say
is that dr. Goulet went on to talk about
human rights which is actually an
outgrowth of liberalism human rights is
an outgrowth of liberalism you cannot
understand human rights without
understanding liberalism therefore the
liberalism that we are talking about
the social liberalism that is the
political philosophy that was well
introduced by John Locke one could argue
some say Thomas Hobbes and has a
tradition all the way up to this day and
so my definition of liberalism is
actually a politically for us
philosophical one which I'm sure he'll
be able to resonate with being a
philosopher himself
traditional Islam I agree with dr.
Goulet we no one has a monopoly of
traditionally the slam so for example I
follow the hambo Light School of Law I
can't say that my school of law is the
only correct one I understand that there
is different strands of traditions islam
martelli's were accepted as part of
their age now for example and that's
even mentioned by Montaigne Ian who is a
literalists as many of you know so I'd
set the nuance there I don't disagree
with him I don't think anyone has a
monopoly of tradition traditional slams
I think that's the first thing the
second thing I want to put to dr. Goulet
is that before we say that we should
move into a liberalizing direction I
think it's very fair to ask the question
how can we prove that liberalism is true
in the first place and of course John
Locke who is the founding father of
liberalism had an essay or a book that
he wrote when he talked about morality
and in that he said that morality is
something which is you can be
demonstrated like mathematics he said
that you can prove the truth of morality
in the same way as you can truth you can
prove scientific truths or mathematical
logical truths in his own system he said
that liberalism is true and he gave
theological reasons for it he replied to
Robert filmer for example who was a
Christian and he was using God as the
example so in other words he was using
an anchorage a moral epistemological
anchorage which was theological and of
course the liberal tradition is not just
John Locke so across time there has been
different philosophers all of which have
tried different things in order to
anchor their respective moral philosophy
so we have John Stuart Mill we have John
rules de Tocqueville
Montesquieu all of these individuals
wrote books and there is a vast wood
there is a rich tradition of referring
back to a particular underpinning
whether it be utilitarianism the
hedonistic principle or whatever but in
any of those cases liberalism has proven
to be a creature of convention what did
you say I said liberalism is a creature
of convention meaning it's a subjective
morality something which is and has been
the subject of change it's not an object
of might therefore before we even
perceived in this conversation you have
to prove to me that liberalism is true I
mean you had a debate with Hamza's or
sir some time ago about God's existence
fifty four minutes into the debate
doctor Goulet said there is no
scientific evidence of God just better
in mind there is no scientific evidence
of God is a problem with his
understanding of philosophy of science
but where is the scientific evidence for
liberalism you can't have one standard
of truth when you're trying to discover
one system of morality and then this
band that discard that completely throw
that out when you're talking about your
own beliefs which are axiomatic
otherwise unprovable so before you tell
us to be liberal why don't you prove
liberalism stop preaching to us and
start proving to us that's the reality
you have taken the stance of an
ideologue a liberal ideologue preacher
don't be a preacher be a teacher don't
be don't preach proof I want to learn
give me some proofs however what we saw
in the second half of the presentation
was dr. GU or Goulet is that he started
talking about discrimination human
rights and all of those things and he
mentioned the death penalty here's my
claim and I stand in front of everyone
today we
full confidence that this claim will not
be refuted listen to the claim
liberalism can and has and is wait a
minute now you're using too many words
I mean rewind liberalism can and has and
is capable of producing death-penalty
outcomes for non allegiance to the state
for example her dude
the laws barbaric outdated dysfunctional
laws which is a genetic fallacy by the
way and you should know as a philosopher
that presents in cases like this is weak
then he mentioned democracy which is
even look it's even older than Mohammed
so it's even more outdated so it should
be even more wrong in your understanding
but then here's what I'm saying to you
the point is this liberalism can allow
why because ladies and gentlemen liberal
contract arianism or contractual ism
which is the only liberalism that you
will find on the face of the earth
assumes that we had a prime model state
of nature and that we entered into a
prime model barter where we traded our
freedom for the security of the state
meaning what the sovereign becomes the
ultimate authority John Locke is himself
said in his letters of toleration
ironically that if someone in a Jewish
state John Locke the founding father of
liberalism someone in a Jewish state a
poster size is this believes in Judaism
he is to be killed when he a minute is
this for Muhammad no no no no this is
John Locke the founding father of
liberalism which is the very ideology
you are trying to preach to us today
this of course did not stop at Locke it
continued to mill it continued all the
way up to rules actually Immanuel Kant
all of these individuals have messages
similar to that that you have to fully
obey the sovereign listen to this listen
to this me and you I was born in London
twenty-eight years ago you were born
maybe 29 years ago I don't know in
Norway and and what happened was I
didn't get a choice did you get a choice
that you had to obey the law or not or
to be a citizen or not I was just forced
into the social contract freedom of
expression and freedom of religious
expression and freedom of thought and so
on and so forth all of that was
curtailed that the very starting point
for me I didn't choose to be here and to
be a citizen and obey the law yet I have
to obey the law the point is the social
contract is is dominant and therefore
when the law is in place I have to
follow the law if the law is that
there's treason which is associated with
some kind of religious authority then
that is the law therefore it's
conceivable through liberalism to have
death penalty outcomes philosophically
and by the way it's also conceivable in
Islam as he alluded to to refer to him
that you don't have to have death
penalty outcomes for a public apostasy
in an Islamic state let me give you the
evidence for that some brothers are
gonna say wait a minute you know you
become liberal no no no no
for example the prophet mohammed salah
isil in a hadith in Bukhari where he was
talking to the people of in had a beer
he spoke too soon alien army and there
was a pact that he created so hey
Lebanon who was the leader of the
collages at that time said that if
anyone opposed Assizes even publicly the
assumption was then they are to be not
killed but returned to us the Prophet
agreed to that now the question is is
this still applicable today if no crime
will josiya he mentions in said mad just
as Elmer Dell we also pronounced murder
we mentions as well in his books no
aliens off the other one he wrote
another big book give the references
after he mentions that this is still
applicable today so it's not been
abrogated in other words it's
conceivable fully to have a fully
fledged Islamic state where there is no
war and someone apostates in public and
there is no death penalty outcome why
is that despite what the Prophet
Muhammad said and because of liberalism
no no this is because of what Prophet
Muhammad said so Allah Allah knows and
therefore it's conceivable in Islam for
such punishments to be waived as well as
implemented fairly and deliberate lism
for such punishments to be waived or
implemented so what's the issue the
issue is you're actually calling us to
something which we don't need we have
within our own system the point is this
as he said correctly there's Muslim the
jurists can and have argued to that
effect now let's look at something else
a point I wanted to make you which I
think we need to be very clear on it's
not to have colonial amnesia the most
bloody massacres in human history
and I say this with full confidence have
been perpetrated by liberal States let's
take one example 1830 the French
annexation of Algeria 1 million people
were killed
genocide oh and by the way I was a
history teacher in the UK for some time
never did we teach this and it wasn't
even on the national curriculum but we
teach about the Holocaust those kinds of
genocides why because the French were
adamant on censoring this information
because it included rape pillaging of
human beings and pictures are them
because this was the time where pictures
could be actually generated many Muslims
don't even know what happened in Algeria
for a hundred and thirty years by a
government a French government which was
not only liberal listen to this but the
founding fathers of that liberal
government and philosophers like Alexis
de Tocqueville in his essays to Algiers
actually supported the colonial
discrimination against who the Algerians
because of what because of the
superiority complex that they had and
this is to be honest what we find in the
discourse is supposed to
purity complex where you don't even have
an objective morality to give us so the
point is this listen to this liberalism
has can allow for racism and colonialism
and tyranny and authoritarianism whereas
Islam can never and what say it has
never but can never as a religion can
never allow for racism
so the question shouldn't really be now
if you if you like racism liberalism
can't stop you from being racist let me
say that one more time
liberalism as a political philosophy
cannot and has not through its
principles or its actions stop you from
being a racist and if it could then
surely the founding fathers surely those
who came after them and those who came
after them wouldn't have allowed a
race-based slavery to exist race-based
slavery in America until the Civil War
which by that were killed the most
people in American history in terms of
Wars so this is a colonial amnesia which
I think people are having and forgetting
about the fact that most genocides that
have been committed in history have been
by literally massive genocides have been
by liberal states in the in the in the
recent history the Native Americans what
happened to them Native America Native
Americans and what happened to them is
is basically Isis on steroids
if you if you don't like Isis you
shouldn't like I mean imagine 100 years
from now you speak to our Isis person
and they say this is our state we've
overtook you from the people no one will
accept it but now America is basically
premise this it's built on the same kind
of genocide and that's the reality this
is liberalism for you yeah
westward expansion manifest destiny
these were all liberal concepts please
don't try it we know your history we
know your history very well and we know
your present as well and the question
now is it can it be legalistically
justified you know I did some research
which I'm going to publish soon
inshallah maybe a week or two I did some
reach research on the amount of times
the Haddad have been implemented in the
Ottoman Empire of course there are gaps
in the
but it has actually been digitized and
archived and my understanding is from
the years 1500 to 1700 there was only
two or three cases and by the way there
was no death penalty outcomes for a lot
of them from the years 1700 to 1856
which is when the Tanzimat took place
when actually in 1839 in 1839 they
basically stopped a Sharia law as being
the arbitrator and Jew in the judiciary
in in the Ottoman Empire in that period
of time we saw the most but most of them
once again through muslin and other
reasons were stopped now look at America
of treason is I believe and not me the
scholars of Islam like his Selassie he
mentions in his mob thought he they say
that that is equivalent to high treason
America in 1862 William Mumford he tore
down an American flag now notice that
this was not an act of militancy this
was an act of symbolism he tore down an
American flag
this was after Abraham Lincoln and all
the founding fathers of liberalism who
wrote the Federalist Papers etc in
America he tore down an American flag
and was executed in front of a mass
amount of people in New Orleans
now this is not militancy so is it
conceivable yes has it been shown in
history yes even through the law so
liberalism doesn't produce non-death
penalty outcomes
that's fake that's false we're not going
to believe in that that's fake history
hasn't proven that bring your evidence
and so the present is even worse because
they don't even use the treatise clause
in the second the second article of the
Constitution of America and they do
extrajudicial killings and by the way
those extrajudicial killings and the
suspension of habeas corpus rights are
sometimes navigated and mitigated
through the liberal constitutional
rights and then you have people like
he'll allow look here's a six-year-old
who was killed by Americans by drones
yes by drones killing a child because
they're afraid that she'll turn out like
her father without any trial
this is liberalism
you in action don't talk to us about
liberalism and does it slam me to be
liberal and outdated democracy is much
older than proof Mohammed's time and he
mentioned it as outdated as if some kind
of argument
this is dysfunctionality in
argumentation actually to use his phrase
moreover liberalism is contradictory
with itself pluralism says that you can
use for example your religious
expression and so on to express yourself
in society circularity or secularism
doesn't allow that so if I'm a Muslim
and I want to use my religious belief
systems to influence policy that's not
allowed to me by secularity or
secularism why is allowed by pluralism
so it's contradictions what if something
which is democratic contradicts
something which is liberal what do you
do in that situation
so here the truth is there is nothing
you can say at all to convince us in the
same way as many colonial forefathers
knot off himself
I'm just saying of the Western people in
general used to come to our countries
and tell us to believe in what they
believe and just like in Algeria we
rejected this because they did not
provide any proof for what they believe
and today we're finding the same thing
again you're not providing any proof so
what I'm going to conclude with is a
list of just three questions the second
one has sub compartments which hopefully
the professor will answer number one is
straightforward give us proof of
liberalism
what kind of demonstrative proof have
you got logical give me a rational
argument using Monty for logic give me a
mathematical argument a scientific one
you can't just produce say be liberal
it's like coming here and say be
communist it's ridiculous
give me some proof number two give us
evidence for the presuppositions of
liberalism you mentioned equality and
freedom how can you even prove that
freedom exists as an atheist material
how much of your materials or not let
alone being a desirable thing you have
to prove this equality that's against a
theory of Darwinian evolution we're not
born equal that's what that's what
mentioned in the documents like the the
United for example the United States
Constitution was it sort of the
Declaration of Independence but how can
you prove that we're all born equal John
Locke said that we are endowed that
equality from God as an atheist how can
you prove equality prove it prove to us
that we're born equal that freedom
exists that is a desirable thing and
that individual rights should be
prioritized over collective rights which
is the basis for most moral liberal
systems you have to prove this and do
you admit that liberalism is capable of
producing legally binding death penalty
outcomes for non allegiance to the state
for example and if so how do you suppose
liberalism solves a problem that is
created by Islam please answer those
questions or salam aleikum wa
rahmatullah wa okay thank you so much
Mohammed hi job for your presentation we
will now have the rebuttal session where
dr. Lodge will have ten minutes to give
his comments on what Muhammad hijab have
spoken and you will have your time on
the timer in front of them
so without any further ado thank you I
must say that I'm surprised by the
mixing here of norm and fact by mr.
haire job because he assumes that we can
prove normativity norms in the same way
that we prove the existence of the Sun
or that we are here today these are two
completely different areas two different
spheres we don't use the same sort of
logic we don't use the same sort of
arguments when we are discussing norms
and when we are discussing facts reality
the descriptive part
of reality so here is a confusion the
confusion that he brings with him into
his presentation of the liberalist
tradition I am NOT in that tradition I
find parts of it sympathetic but he is
and it seems to me that he is reading
every text as a Salafi as something that
is there like the Quran unchangeable for
eternity the whole point with a
tradition in Pella in political
philosophy is that it develops of course
we do think and say liberals do you
think and say something different from
what John Locke said that is the whole
point of a philosophical tradition is
that those who follow John Locke looked
at what he wrote and so ah he's mistaken
I can do better we can improve and those
that followed him again says the same
thing
so liberalism now I'm speaking as a
teacher is different today than it was
at John Locke's
time and to say that we have to go back
to John Locke to understand liberalism
is plainly nonsense I'm sorry it doesn't
make any sense because liberalists today
say something else than what John Locke
said and wrote so so here there is a
confusion and actually a a rather
strange if not to say naive presentation
of the liberal tradition in political
philosophy of course people within the
liberal tradition are affected by the
circumstances John Locke was a Christian
many liberals political liberals today
are not religious they say and mean
different things and how the tradition
how the contradictions within the
traditions has been addressed and
changed
mr. job is quite correct in the liberal
tradition that has been raised it racist
attitudes there has been arguments for
the death penalty it has been practiced
and liberal
and legitimized justified by liberals
today if we say that liberal political
philosophy liberal political thinking is
predominant and there is a case for that
in the Western world today look at
Europe today they have all abolished the
death penalty so to argue that John
Locke was in favor of the death penalty
400 years ago and relating that to
liberalism today is simply absurd it
doesn't make any sense because
liberalism today is completely different
and then what about cannot avoid it
because if you are saying that Islam is
Islam and it's perfect from the
beginning and that is absolute there is
no relativity here it's the same
throughout the centuries because the
basis is the same the Quran is the same
and the Sunnah is there yes what about
today no you cannot you cannot justify
racism in Islam about the equal number
of slaves transported to the Americas
was captured and sold from Africa into
the Muslim world over several centuries
wasn't that racism and if you think it
is appeared well some time ago because
today we preach a more enlightened form
of Islam you're wrong some of you with
black skin having been in the Middle
East would know that skin racism skin
color racism racism is still prevalent
in the Middle East
don't tell me otherwise I have spoken to
blacks black Muslims studying Islam in
Syria telling me how they have faced
racism in that country amongst Muslims
and if you say that well the West they
have been doing committing atrocities it
is true and who who are those who have
addressed those atrocities critique to
them made interpretations of politics
change
well they are the same people in the
West criticizing France for its
occupation of Algeria where are the
Muslims protesting against Saudi Arabia
Muslims killing children Muslim children
in Yemen today where are they where are
all the Muslims protesting against Saudi
Arabia's killing of Karachi a year ago
don't tell me that oh you are to blame
for this and that colonialism what about
Islamic colonialism what about Islamic
imperialism oh no we just spread the
word we didn't use soldiers at all we
didn't conquer Spain you know we just
persuaded the Spaniards to become
Muslims I am not the one who says that
Islam was mainly spread by the sword
because that is not true but it was also
spread by the sword
jihad visible Allah don't tell me
otherwise so if you are saying that your
interpretations of this and that
political philosophy is different from
then you are comparing bad Western
practices with Islamic ideals you're not
looking at Islamic practices and
comparing them with Western ideals and
that is also a fallacy finally there are
many things that could be said here but
but finally when it comes to the liberal
tradition again mr. job is asking for
proofs and he's saying that liberalism
is based on a fallacy on something that
cannot be proven but that's true
no one pretended that the state of
nature could be proven at least not
today it might have been a hypothesis
that Thomas Hobbes John Locke thought
was plausible also in the empirical
sense not least because of the colonial
experience but the
fact is that when most of the liberal
theoreticians talk about a state of
nature it is a hypothesis it's illogical
hypothesis they use to establish
premises that you can use to argue in
favor of certain moral ethical
principles we're not talking about facts
we are talking about norms we are
talking about the basis for a logical
argument that can justify individual
freedom the states need to withdraw from
total domination of the individual and
so on so again there is a confusion of
the empirical and the normative and mr.
hijabs presentation which I find very
very strange finally if there is such a
thing that well we are influenced by
this and that and we have the colonial
past and colonialism is wrong why why is
colonialism wrong I would like to have
mr. hijab answer that because if he says
it's wrong because and I agree with him
then we have something common in spite
his religious starting point and my
non-religious starting point and that is
what is interesting me so to comment on
the questions and I cannot do but
comment on them I don't need to give
proofs of liberalism it doesn't make any
sense first of all I'm not a liberal
list in the philosophical sense and
second it is a sort of system that
cannot be given proofs it can be shown
to be consistent or inconsistent and
because of certain of its inconsistency
I am NOT a political liberal so there
and I've just commented on the evidence
of liberalism presupposition the state
of nature born equal etc born equal yes
are you saying that we are not born
equal
that is also hypothesis of course when
when Rousseau's
that we were born equal he did not
necessarily mean that in a literal
empirical sense but he said when the
baby comes out of the mother they are
equal some grows up slaves some grow up
as labourers some will be princes and
rulers of course he knew that it wasn't
a stupid man but he made a premise that
you have to argue why we are not equal
that is the important thing
so liberalism can produce various
outcomes as we have seen but so will
Islam as we have seen thank you thank
you dr. lush for your rebuttal now we
will have Mohammed hijab giving his ten
minutes of comments so I'm very happy
with that actually a lot of that is
exactly what I wanted to hear
he said liberalism cannot be proven and
then he said we're born equal and he
said to me the burden was a of proof is
on me well actually no the burden of
proof is on the one who's making the
claim the burden of proof is not on me
to prove I were not equal because that's
demonstrative when we're born out of the
mother's womb some of us are tall tall
dark and handsome like myself and some
of us yes and some of us are not and
certainly I'm not saying you right and
so on okay no what are we equal in we're
not equal in physical characteristics
we're not equal an opportunity some of
us are born in different geographic
locations some of us are born in in the
east west north south whatever it may be
what is equal about our opportunities or
our physical characteristics from a
strictly scientific perspective there's
nothing equal about how we're born at
all no the burden of proof is not on me
the burden of proof is definitely on you
now having said that we do believe in an
equal spiritual opportunity from an
Islamic perspective we can say that by
arguing from first principles the
problem is you can't argue from first
principles as admitted by yourself
because you need and
a systemic vantage point which doesn't
have the end as the beginning this is
how you argue in your debates you start
by saying Human Rights is a good thing
but you have no way of proving that
according to your own admission your
understanding of Human Rights
you cannot say I'm not a liberal now
because you've been promoting human
rights all your life that's what you've
been doing how can you not be a liberal
and Human Rights is a birth child of
liberalism is a birth child of
liberalism and you've been promoting it
harassing Muslims in debates telling
them you have to be this and you have to
be that and you cannot even prove human
rights because you cannot even prove
it's seedbed epistemic seed bed which is
liberalism don't run away from the
question saying that liberalism in his
definition is lack of strictness all I
can say the Prophet said don't be strict
but that's according to our
understanding our jurisprudential
understanding of strictness you have to
have a when you say strict what do you
mean you're talking about in like
post-enlightenment ideas this is perfect
this is the trap mode and then he's
tried to say because right now he's
running away from it sorry to say I'm
not trying to push you into a corner
but why I'm saying is he came today and
tried to equivocate it's called the
fallacy of equivocation use the
dictionary definition of the word
liberalism when all his life he's been
using the political philosophical
definition of liberalism and by the way
the dictionary definition is informed by
the political definition to run away
from proving what he has to prove that's
the reality of what's happened today
then he says talks about discrimination
not as confusing feminism with
liberalism says why I want women in the
back and men in the front this is a
second wave feminists ik interrogation
why should we go for a second wave
feminist ik interrogation not a third
wave feminist ik interrogation which
would ask you by a third wave feminists
would ask you how do you know they're
women have you asked who their pronouns
now honestly honestly how did you know I
mean a queer studies theory would say
that so you're trying to force us you
don't even know what you're arguing for
that's the reality of situation you've
come here with a gun with no bullets and
you shout the wrong man
because the reality is now you're being
questioned on your own ideology he says
don't look liberalism has changed since
John Locke if you listen to what I said
I said I don't care what John Locke said
I said it's the principles of liberalism
I use John Locke as a supporting
argument not as a main argument saying
that everything that John Locke says is
liberalism I said that contract arian
forms of liberalism or otherwise were
referred to as contractual forms which
are the only forms you'll see in the
whole wide world
give me one Robert Nozick style utopian
anarchy in his book I'm sure you've read
it non-contract arian form of a
liberalism on the earth today you won't
find it
therefore what's happened today is it's
as if I was debating someone about
Christianity and Trinity and say look
actually I don't really believe in
Christianity I only believe in parts of
it so of course you're gonna run away
from the question because you have to
prove yourself at this point and when
neo liberal yes Orientalists
commentators are questioned on their
principles they retreat they run away
from answering and if they do answer
they'll be honest like he has been to be
fair so I can't prove this and at the
end he tried to kind of run away from it
say actually you have to prove that
we're not born equal but actually no you
have to prove that we are equal because
that's the metaphysical equality it's a
metaphysical or it's not a physical one
you can't argue that we're physically
equal we're definitely so if you're some
metaphysical claim it requires
metaphysical proofs you have to provide
that he says well this racism in the
Middle East I agree with you but there's
racism against black people and racism
against Filipinos and raised them
against you know even Arabs race against
themselves and racism is a problem and I
agree with all of what you said there I
don't have any a disagreement with you
on these points but that's a straw man I
doesn't say anything about I'm not here
to defend the Middle East if I was here
defending lily's I promise you he'd win
the debate I'm here to defend slam call
Aloha Rasul Allah and the messenger I
don't care what the Muslims do Muslims
are only applicable to the discussion if
they form part of the a Jamaa for
example in a juice Prudential sense he
says
Islamic colonialism well look even if
there was Islamic colonialism I was made
very clear I can't hit stand here and
defend a thousand four hundred years of
Islamic history very clearly if there
was Islamic colonialism with the
connotations that implies and you asking
me to condemn it which is a
misappropriation of land taking people
out of their homes that's wrong we don't
believe in that but we do believe in an
age of empire where there was a medieval
realist form in and international
relations perspective of power relations
if you know your neighbor is about to
take you over and you have two choices
as a government then it's not morally
objectionable from my perspective to
offer them the ultimatum first it's not
a UN style a situation where we can
agree and Islam says Islam says if there
are peace treaties in place to stop that
from happening and we're sure that our
neighbors will not do that then those
peace treaties must be respected so if
my neighbor if I was living in the
medieval period and my neighbor my read
Geographic neighbor said I'm not going
to you know coming to you it trying to
overtake you
you don't overtake us and there was an
agreement I would say it's Haram wrong
morally unacceptable for them to invade
but unless the neighbor can provide such
guarantees then I would say it becomes
possible and an option in that in that
context because you either get eat
either you're gonna get eaten as you
would say in a in a pie graph in a
biological sense Darwinian sense so
really these are the points and he said
that men and women let's say let's take
the gender the dichotomous second wave
feminists think how is that
discrimination against women as well men
and women get exactly the same thing if
men can't go into women's area women
can't go into men's area isn't that the
same isn't that the rights of men a
woman exactly the same in that situation
how can you say that that's
discrimination against women it doesn't
make any sense because if the same rules
apply to men to women and that's
actually a form of equality now the
question is why do you allow certain
separations in certain contexts and from
UK we have girls schools
boys schools that's an educational
setting this is an educational site I've
never seen you condemn that
while you condemn that while you condemn
certain separate it why because the
white man said so that's the reality
when the white will liberal man decides
this is an acceptable form of separation
which has no problem with our
sensibilities then we have to hear some
a no apana we have to hear and obey the
colonial overlords no that's weak give
us some proof you've just come here and
said well John Locke liberalism has
changed therefore run away no you come
here to a debate that is entitled does
Islam me to be liberalized you need to
show us first
why liberalism is true and desirable
before you can convince us of that I
know that Muslims have a bad track
record but what I'll say to you is this
as Muslims what are we calling you to in
the last minute I will say this we're
calling you to forget about the
hedonistic principle where the
procurement of pleasure is the main
thing we're saying constricts your
pleasures in the same way as a loss of
Hana Italia has constricted the laws of
the heavens in the earth has constricted
the laws of nature we are saying as
Muslims we would rather constrict
ourselves on our behavior constrain our
behaviors in line with the de vanga
divine guidance
alas in the Quran which is actually a
response to liberalism I believe by the
audible mention he says
well oh it devil ha
laughs essa that is some too well oh man
well attain me the cream from the cream
if the heavens in the earth had followed
their desires everything in the heavens
and earth would have been destroyed we
have come with the reminder the reminder
is to follow allah slaws instead of
following your own whims and desires
which is the essence of liberalism the
hedonistic principle and then you'll
find meaning in life we should change
the title today after this discussion
too should liberalism be Islam Assizes
like an all-hands in a lacunae thank you
Mohamed hijab for your rebuttal we will
now have our cross examination where
each speaker will have one minute to
phrase his question to his opponent and
and the other speaker will have three
minutes to answer his question and each
speaker will be given three questions
each after that we will open up the
floor for the questions from the
audience
so we will start with dr. Lodge with his
first question that he would like to ask
Mohammed Haeju
I have just a couple of of question
first I didn't think it was necessary to
emphasize that I actually know that
there are a difference between men and
women when they are born black and white
we know that some people will be big and
burly some will be short of course again
then this has to do with physical
reality reality and that's not when what
we are talking about when we are talking
about human dignity and human Worth and
it is in that respect that we are equal
and my question first person is are we
of equal or
earth regardless men women born from
believers or unbelievers in this
normative sense okay to answer that
question directly we are born equal so
then the problem Hamas ilaria celebs
doesn't hadith from our perspective
coulomb alluding you would add value
throught e
there every born baby is born among with
the fitrah fitrah is a disposition to
believe in God so from a spiritual
perspective we're all equal and we are
not to be punished as well unless we
have equal opportunity to receiving the
message so allah says in the quran when
i couldn't my zubeen I had tenebrous
Allah in Chapter 17 verse number 15 we
were not going to punish them until we
sent prophets and by extension that
means we're not going to punish them
until we send someone to tell them the
message of tawheed which should resonate
with them instantaneously from a
monotheistic perspective because we have
an implanted primordial nature or as
they cooperate an autograph of God in us
obviously we don't accept the
phraseology of that but the idea is is
that we have a receptivity to use Justin
Barrett's terms who is in fact Justin
bar I'm saying is name correctly he was
the lead project lead in Oxford
University in the anthropological
society in 2011 who concluded 3m
basically checking out young children
that we do have in his words and in a
receptivity to believe in God or a
higher power so from these perspectives
from both an empirical perspective in an
experiential one we have good evidence
to prove that we are born believing in a
higher power and from an Islamic
perspective therefore we are born equal
in terms of dignity and in terms of
worth value no child born to for example
disbelieving parents is any less
valuable from that perspective than a
child born to believing parents and the
Prophet Muhammad Allah said in a hadith
Rufio Alcala man telleth
he says that the pen has been lifted
upon three people and now M hotta is
Turkish
sleeping person until he is woke up was
sabe you had a Elam and the and the
child until they become pubescent well
much known had died a pill and the the
basically the insane until they become
sane so Islam is a religion which can
anchor your belief system to a spiritual
metaphysical type of equality now he's
right he said that physically we're no
equal but he's making a metaphysical
claim you see the point I was making was
it's impossible unless you argue from
first principles convincingly with the
systemic vantage point other than that
which your end goal in mind first which
is a circular type of reasoning to prove
on liberalism or any other ideology that
we are born equal from a metaphysical
perspective and that was exactly the
point so I agree with him physically
we're different but metaphysically which
is what he's talking about you can't
prove that we're equal but we can thank
you well make a jump for your answer now
you will have one minute to phrase your
question to dr. lush okay I found it
quite bizarre to be honest to be fair to
you dr. Cooley that you tried to use
dictionary definitions to escape
defending the ideology that you've been
promulgating for many years in this
country with the proof of many debates
that you've had for example on human
rights I found even more bizarre that
when I checked the dictionary when it
used the word liberalized some
dictionary definition actually said
especially in regards to politics and
economy economics my question is how do
you decide what definition you're going
to base your arguments of for example we
used the word liberalize while another
word is religion ml Durkheim who we've
seen is like the founding father of
sociology said religion encompass any
metal ideas which include liberalism
actually so from this perspective how
can you and why would you choose some
selective definitions over others to
escape from answering questions thank
you perfect when we use definitions we
try to fill concept
concepts with meaning and a concept is
not true or false the concept cannot be
proven it is not a premise in a logical
argument as such a concept is something
that should be relevant and should be of
interest to the subject matter that we
are trying to understand this is
difficult but it is also very important
because many things that definitions are
true or false they are not they are
chosen they should not be chosen
arbitrarily they should be relevant to
the subject that we are discussing the
investigating this is very important and
when I am asked the question should
Islam be liberalized and I myself is not
an ardent defender of the political
philosophy of liberalism I'm looking at
more or less common-sense definition
what we call definitions of use how how
can we understand liberalisation in a
common-sense way and then you can go to
dictionaries you will find nuances in
those dictionaries and I made it very
simple for myself because I googled and
that comes up the Oxford the internet
dictionary and so on well that was
sufficient to make my point that we are
talking about changing certain dogmas
beliefs practices that is my point I
don't have to prove premises or the
basis not that that is a very strange
way of approaching this it's a very
Islamist way of approaching it I can say
that's that's his right okay so so be it
he can ask me to do that
but I don't see that as necessarily just
a point about my own position yes I
define human rights didn't defend human
rights I've been doing so for quite a
number of years
and of course there is a certain liberal
element in that I don't deny that the
history of human rights has been
strongly influenced by political
liberalism but you don't have to be a
political liberalist in order to defend
human rights can be a social democrat
you can be a Marxist you can be an
anarchist you can have many different
positions you can even be a Muslim and
if any human rights so you can defend
those from many different perspectives
coming to human worth it was a very
interesting answer because mislay job
has his position it's given to us by God
human Worth and dignity is given to us
by God I have a different story about
the origins of human dignity and human
rights then we have a liberal
philosopher John Rawls who is talking
about overlapping consensus we disagree
about the basic reasons but we agree on
the conclusion that we have human
dignity and human right the human worth
as an inherent value and that we can
build on even if we agree disagree on
the causes or reasons behind that worth
thank you dr. Gulen
may you phrase your question - yes it's
very simple it's colonialism wrong
because God says so or do we have a
common ground for saying that
colonialism is wrong thank you dr. lush
thank you just a comment on what was
just said in terms of popular usage or
academic usage the word liberalize is
certainly used to refer to popular
political philosophy and I'll give you
some usages here for example a book with
an anthology of different thinkers were
called towards an Islamic Reformation
civil liberties human rights and
international law this liberalized means
the political philosophy I said Talal
Asad here Oh a book ooh blasphemy injury
and free speech whenever
throughout liberalize he's referring to
the political philosophy John Charvet
who is LSE professor whenever he used
the word liberalize he used as a
political philosophy for example Evans
who's whose is in Britain he wrote a
book called liberal terror when ever
used the word liberalized he means the
political philosophy gray John Gray when
he wrote the book black mass whenever
you use the word liberalized he means it
in terms of political philosophy so if
we're talking about usage I don't think
you can argue that when people use the
word liberalized in the English language
that that means to make things less
strict even the dictionary you said
Oxford says with particular reference to
economics and politics now to answer
your question directly that we can say
there's something called divine command
theory which is divine command Theory
first I should I should premise this by
saying there's a difference of opinion
among Muslim scholars that would be the
most correct thing to say so this is
something called a takbir attack seen in
an Islamic moral theory and some people
have said that takbir hota seen or being
able to discern morality with fitrah
Salima is something which you can do
intuitively it when taymiyah said this
but he prayed he said that you can do it
you can find our intuitive morality only
but sometimes is very difficult to
realize what is actually socialized and
what isn't socialized so he says that in
order for you to be sure you have to go
to the textual evidences the ushe are a
school of thought are more in line with
divine command theory Marta cities say
it's to be they believe in terribly hard
a scene so there is a discussion among
Muslim scholars I can't tell you that
this is the way and this is the truth in
there there is a discussion but in my
understanding I think a combination of
views would talk about the scene in
Tamiya's V where he said about Fatah
is true with divine command theory as
well I think that's true is also looking
at what God said and looking at the
Sunnah is not the only access point to
morality yeah so we
you believe in intuitive which is
actually what John Locke believed is
intuitive morality as well however it's
a it's a way to save out those true
morality is from false morality I think
it's a bit of a complicated answer but
yeah thank you thank you for answer
would you pose your second question yes
dr. gulam third question how many
questions
yes second for hijab that's what I said
because you asked the first question and
you have one more question left and here
one exactly exactly I have one more
question and it will relate to nobody
but it's oh sorry yes okay you're not
trying to impinge on my freedom of
speech I I wanna do I'm talking about
freedom of speech and but particularly
the thirty articles of the human rights
which are school a large Cooley has
adamantly vehemently defended in the
past which I maintain our liberal
outgrowths one of them is democracy one
of the you know human rights is
democracy however I'll give you a
scenario I want you to answer the
scenario would you consider it
democratically legitimate if a state
were to carry out a referendum and
conclude that they want amputation for
thieves as an appropriate punishment and
if not why not
thank you the answer is no and that is
because of human rights and the question
is very relevant in the West because we
have had since 2001 a so-called war on
terror in that war on terror the
Americans found it reasonable they try
to justify it through law arguments that
we can torture suspects in the war on
terror between 60 and 80 percent of
Americans polled on this question said
it was acceptable it is not
acceptable you have no right to infringe
the basic human rights of everyone even
the criminal with the infliction of
torture that is an absolute prohibition
in human rights totally unacceptable
so if you say God has said we should
amputate the hand of the thief that is a
clear example of how certain commands in
Islam are against human rights and
therefore not compatible with modern
human rights thinking actually rather
few states including Muslim states
practice this I think it was Habib
Bourguiba who's known it was actually it
was actually the second-in-command in
Libya in there Gaddafi who had his
special interpretation of Islam and it
was criticized for that but he said it
was Islam and they should follow Islam
in many ways and this guy was asked why
don't you amputate the hand of the thief
he said no we can't have a we can't have
you know a stock of labor's with only
one hand we need people who can work
with both hands which is a rational way
of saying that it is not a completely
outdated method of of punished
punishment for rational reasons but the
main fact is that it is a cruel and
inhumane punishment and therefore it
should not be practiced this represents
a challenge and a problem for a number
of Muslims who want to maintain that the
will of God is clear and at the same
time defend human rights very
interesting person in this regard is is
Abdullah Naima Sudanese scholar who is
trying to square the circle but
recognizes that here there is an
absolute challenge and opposition
between
modern human rights thinking and certain
demands of the Sharia thank you doctor
loss you may pose your third and last
question yes that question relates to
the interesting point you made about the
various interpretations on human dignity
and human worth because then you were
approaching some of the rational
arguments that we have human dignity and
human worth because we are rational
beings and that leads me to a question
may be more out of curiosity than of
specific relevance to the this debate
but still what do you think of the
contributions of the philosophers in the
Islamic tradition I'm thinking about
philosophers like Farabi even Sina also
a little Sally but not least even rushed
because they emphasized that should as
good Muslims perhaps with the exception
of as early in this context should as
good Muslims we should use reason and
there is there should be no
understanding of an opposition between
reason and revelation
thank you dr. Lodge actually I've
written a book on this which I only give
to you here this is available online on
Amazon it's called Kalam cosmological
arguments all the names he just
mentioned are mentioned in the book has
aliens seen them the most I'm gonna give
you one the other books will come out on
liberalism and apostasy which I'm going
to bring out hopefully next week or the
week after and another one I'm gonna
have actually written called fifth wave
feminism in peer-reviewed as well so
hopefully I can send you those over or
something yeah so I'll quickly come back
to something that was said and then
answer your question directly the the
premise that barbarity equals falsity
because we heard he says something about
cutting the hands
he says it's barbaric cruel and barbaric
I think that's cruel and inhumane as to
words he used but just because something
is cruel it doesn't mean is false that's
a fallacy actually that's that is a
fallacious kind of reasoning barbarity
does not equal falsity and in fact war
is an industry or barbarity and cruelly
cruelty war is an industry of barbarity
and cruelty and unless you're a pacifist
you endorse that kind of barbarity and
that kind of cruelty you actually went
and tried to get involved in it yourself
I mean so so who gets to decide which
kind of barbarity and cruelty is
legitimate and which kind of barbarity
and cruelty is illegitimate and moreover
nothing is here we talked about the vote
you know if if a Muslim country for
example voted that they wanted
amputation of the thieves of the hand
should he said it's against human rights
but I don't of the 30 articles I don't
see the right to have a hand as one of
them actually the right to have a vote
was one of them and the right for a
state to be sovereign is another one so
here you have clear contradictions
between human rights which is what my
esteemed interlocutor is not telling us
that these human rights which are
predicated on axiomatic unprovable first
premises are actually human rights which
are outgrowth of liberalism and which
have no proof as we've seen it seen
today moreover they contradict each
other
sovereignty of state versus democracy
versus life versus is that is why I ask
them the question because if you say
well even if 99% of the population don't
one sorry they want application of hands
of Thieves we're not going to have it
this is in fact going against the human
right of democracy so you can you can't
have your cake in it you both it's going
to be a contradiction I'm afraid you're
gonna have to enjoy that contradiction
as for has I'll even seen herself
amazing scholars I'll say you can read
the book as a right to have the
philosopher and I think they're all had
an incredible impact on one another but
yeah I'd read the book for sure that
will give you an insight because it's I
can't I can't do it into two minutes I
think it's very difficult Thank You mr.
jab
you may pose your third and last
question to dr. Gouda okay I think you
can see that that slavery colonialism
racism and punitive punishments are all
principally conceivable in a liberal
state if so as a defender of Human
Rights which is an outgrowth of
liberalism why do you use them as main
arguments against this level sorry let
me let me say that one more time can I
repeat it yeah so I said I think in the
course of your presentation you conceded
that slavery colonialism racism etc
punitive punishments are all possible
conceivably possible in a state which is
liberal or even says that we follow
human rights a state that predicates
itself on human rights values therefore
if this is the case what you said how
isn't it fruitless to try and call us to
this because the conceivability of it
being implemented does not change in
fact you could argue it may even
increase based on historical data it's
conceivable and actually we see
violations of human rights every day all
over the world including in countries
saying that they are defending human
rights it's a continuous struggle but
the fact that something is not respected
fully doesn't mean that it is not right
to defend those human rights so of
course the the fact that people are are
anyway hypocrites or not practicing what
the ideals say that they should practice
doesn't mean that they that the ideals
are baseless and for example if we
should accept this ultra Democratic
position that the majority can decide
okay we now would like to torture
suspects in the war on terror or we
should cut off the hand of Thieves
then we are free to out vote Islam in
Norway and believe me that is not
impossible
we have strong parties groups advocating
prohibiting Islam in Norway and if you
say it's a democratic right goodbye why
is it wrong because you have human
rights because Muslims have the right to
practice their religion in the country
where the majority is opposed to it and
if you don't stand up for that right
when it comes to others not to be
mistreated not to have their religion
banned etc why should we accept your
right to be practicing Muslims in Norway
against the will of the majority if you
don't understand that a modern democracy
is not the rule of the majority or in
majority tyranny but it is always a
tempered democracy it's a democracy with
respect for the individual and groups of
individuals who want to live their lives
the way they see fit which is what I
emphasized in my introductory remarks we
are talking about the right of
individuals coming together in groups in
congregations in mosques to live their
lives as they want to do it even if it
provokes me even if I am don't like it
what should I do
I should defend the right to do this
while I at the same time use my freedom
of expression to critique religion to
critique these practices as I have done
today but if someone comes here and
tries to take those rights away from you
I will stand up and defend your right to
be Muslims the way you want to be
Muslims
[Applause]
thank you dr. Gouda that's the
conclusion
can I just add because I'm also a book
it's actually my doctoral dissertation a
little bit thicker than mr. jobs book
but this is actually an attempt to not
prove because I don't think that is
possible but an attempt to logically
justify human rights and I think it is a
fairly valid proposition that I'm making
so I will give this one to mr. hijab
[Applause]
[Music]
it's good to see that love is in there
so that concludes our second this is
actually the third session yeah first
one was the introduction second one was
the rebuttals and this one was the
interrogations so now is the last and
final session where the audience will
have the opportunity to ask the
respective questions to each speaker at
a time so first question will be to
mohammad hijab do we have any question
from to mohammad hijab from the gents
side or from the women's area any
questions no questions everything made
sense he won the debate so over and done
no okay any questions you may also send
your questions by message to our
Facebook page the Islam that Facebook
page if you wish you could send your
question to the Facebook page but
preferably we have the microphones
available and you will be given priority
if you step forward to the microphones
yeah yeah sure any questions for
Muhammad hijab
no questions yes yes okay come to the
microphone you may choose any microphone
you wish
I just uh thank you I just have one
question about what do you mention about
all the practice about cutting with your
punishment don't you think it's cruel I
think it is definitely it's not nice to
watch Xena but that's the whole point
some things need to be cruel we need to
be cruel to be fair sometimes the point
is this is that first and foremost is it
always applicable I think that's the
first question as it's not always
applicable that someone has to have
their amputee hand amputated but I think
the system of ethics of Islam is
different to the system of ethics of
liberalism so liberalism assumes that we
own our bodies and by the way that says
that's another thing you cannot prove by
the way you cannot prove logically or
metaphysically that you own your own
body you cannot prove that it's
impossible to prove on first principles
let alone your children which some have
stated actually in the literature
however when we say this that there are
some deterrents which are for example
cutting the hand of the thief and so on
which can apply sometimes in certain
situations we're admitting that this is
something which is not and the Quran
actually says when it talks about the
huddle Xena
it says wealth can be a marathon fee if
you didn't laughs include him taught me
no nobility with your man laughing in
chapter 24 verse number 2 says when
you're applying the punishment don't
have compassion in your heart when
you're applying the punishment meaning
there's a natural inclination to feel
like this is a bit this is a bit much
it's a bit you know however a lot of
thing despite this carry out the
punishment and the reason why is because
it has a deterrent effect now if you
look out for example the death penalty
in states where it's actually
implemented in the United States for
example
and compare it to states where there has
there is not implementation of them
murder rates are much higher in states
which don't implement the death penalty
that's a fact reoffending rates in the
UK about 30% of people riaf end
burglars reoffending that's one and
three people in prison have got to come
out and do it again so the whole point
of while cutting the hand off it reduces
reoffending rate it's very effective
it's scary
especially if people are watching it
this instills fear in the people's minds
we have a problem in in in London people
are being stabbed you know we have
thirty thousand stabbings a year and
because the gang members they are
stabbing they don't don't care about the
risk of going to prison that's the
bottom line the fear is not there in
their hearts if you don't have fearful
Authority like Emile Durkheim would say
then you can do whatever you want so the
point is it hasn't it has an intentional
deterrent effect now arguing as large
schoola has said going against human
rights are wrong because you have human
rights that is a circular argument
that's exactly what he said
he said it's wrong because you have it's
wrong to go against human rights because
you have human rights but how do you
prove you have human rights the way
you've described them this is the
problem in this debate that you cannot
prove your first premises therefore
there's no way of disproving this kind
of thing thank you thank you we have one
question to dr. gula you mentioned that
you believe in the human rights so I
will just summarize what I understood
you mentioned that you believe in human
rights and that if there was a
referendum to vote that Muslims should
be deported that would be wrong
because of the human rights but if there
was a referendum in terms of deciding
these human rights that it is okay to
discriminate against religion what would
you then do because what are your human
rights based upon at the end of the day
it's a there are human beings that came
together and decided or voted or
majority-minority whatever they did they
agree that these are the human rights
how would you
this question reality is reality if the
majority decides to throw Muslims out of
Norway they say we have a right to do so
and they change the laws well
Muslims could try to bring the case in
for the human rights court in Strasbourg
but if the majority had already decided
it wouldn't mean anything that is the
whole point of human rights
they are only respected as long as we
recognize them as important and valuable
that's why it's a daily struggle Germany
was a very democratic state in the late
20s and early 30s and it ended up with
Hitler and the abolition of democracy
that evolution of all sorts of liberal
values and ended up with with the
Holocaust a genocide that is why there
are no guarantees enemy okay we replace
this with God and the will of God so
what guarantee do you have for anything
then just a short comment I think you
may have misunderstood the question okay
because from what I understood he's
asking that who are those who actually
decide which human rights or what are
the human rights who have the right to
decide or define that these are because
you keep us
okay referring back to human rights but
these human rights are not god-given so
who is the one who where do they come
from that is a very good question and
the answer is that human rights are
actually in continuous development we've
had some basic human rights
understanding of what human rights
should be but it has varied over time
they have developed one example is
gender equality when they when the
Declaration of Human Rights was accepted
in 1948 it doesn't say one
thing about sexual minorities today it
is human rights law at least in Europe
that sexual minorities homosexuals have
equal rights should not be discriminated
because of their sexual proclivities we
have seen that even though the
Declaration and later on the conventions
legally binding conventions were meant
to give respect to women
it wasn't follow up team practice
therefore we deepened the rights of
women in a particular convention and so
on we have now the Convention on the
Rights of the Child who thought about
children in 1948 in 1966 so this is a
continuous development where everyone
can have their same in the public debate
thank you dr. guna and we have a
question for mohammad hijab from the
microphone right yeah I just wondering
why should we approve things from first
principles and how can you decide that
the accepted method for proving things
is the first principle from the first
principles thank you why should we prove
things from first principles there's
more than one way of proving things from
first principles is one of the ways you
can prove things from a logical
perspective there are other ways from
induction from abduction from some kind
of deduction which sometimes relies on
some kind of induction or abduction
there are different ways of proving
things in the world that's why the
scientific method works and by the way
weird we don't know against the
scientific method in fact we invented
the scientific method Muslims invented
the scientific method so the point of
there being a contradiction between
Islam and and the scientific method is
something I didn't respond to however we
know from the philosophy of science that
science is not incorrigible
so it's something which is subject to
change in fact Karl Popper said that
this was the thing that made science
what is it's false
my ability in his words having said all
of this to answer your question we don't
need to prove it from first principles
but what I was trying to do with my
esteemed interlocutor today was let him
use the same standards as he was using
with us when we were having to prove
God's existence which is metaphysical
right because God we wouldn't say is
physically dwelling in the sense that
he's can be detected by a microscope or
some telescope or something he asked us
for evidence in that respect so I wanted
to ask him for evidence using his very
methods of inquiring truth and what he
admitted today was that there's a
difference between facts and normativity
normativity means how something has
become part of the discourse of let's
say normality yeah so that's of course I
agree with this fact and normativity are
two different separate things it doesn't
have to be separate and it doesn't have
to be disjunct however what I will say
is if you're gonna make a case and tell
us to be something whether it's
believing Human Rights the 30 articles
which as the question and was quite
right in pointing out was a collection
of people that came in the UN Convention
1948 and decided on what 30 30 points
should be the human rights and that this
in his words is correct it's a
development meaning we keep changing
your mind what he means by development
is social forces are continually coming
back and asking questions whoever has
the loudest voice wins at the end one of
the human rights is not your right to
tribal lineage it's because tribalism is
not part of the Western orient sorry the
Western post-colonial narrative so it's
usually what happens in the West will
trickle down to the rest of the were
important in the West and that's another
issue with human rights there are many
issues with human rights they focus too
much on rights what you're owed and not
enough on duties what you owe that's why
you don't have any mothers rights in in
the thirty conventions of all the things
you've been mentioning do your right to
be good to your parents there's not one
of the rights is it can you imagine so
the point I'm making to you is you can't
you can't tell us to believe in
something which in your own admission is
not provable it's not static it's not
incorrigible and it's fluid and
subjective that's
fair I believe that's that's
unscientific as well thank you job I
would take one question here from to dr.
Lodge the question is about the doctor
mentioning that we have to evolve in our
ones in our understanding of human
rights so 50 years ago homosexuality was
not acceptable in accordance to human
rights now today we do accept
homosexuality in a Western liberal
society but some people are now arguing
also that we should accept incest
between brothers and sisters who
willingly participate in that kind of
relationship if there are prevention etc
and some people are also arguing that we
should accept or make it illegal to have
sexual intercourse with animals as
actually has been practiced in Denmark
for years and that it was a it was
actually in the news as well that people
from Norway they take sexual vacations
to Denmark to have sexual intercourse
with animals so people today are arguing
something and in the future they might
argue different things so how do we
reconcile the should we just go along
with whatever we now feel is morally
correct how do we define these
boundaries where are the boundaries of
moral morally correct why is it for
example not okay to have to have what
you disco yes for example mild
pedophilia that you for example a man
masturbates to a baby a baby wouldn't
take any harm of that from your values
what you should not do which is
unacceptable is that which harms someone
else incest is usually understand
understood as they a sex sexual
violation of the rights of a child if
you're talking about grownups who cares
I don't this is really a minority
question
and as a matter of fact there are
instances of the sexual intercourse
between consenting adults resulting in
children and the biological argument
that this is harmful to the baby has a
very weak foundation actually it's more
of a problem that cousins marry again
and again and again because that limits
the genetic pool that a brother and
sister on one occasion marries and have
a child it's not a big genatech problem
do I like it would I say hooray this is
great no why not why not well why should
I
I mean I wouldn't you do the same for
the homosexuals i right to practice I am
not gay and why why should I why should
I say because I accept the right of gays
to be gay and practice there with
consult consenting adults their sexual
proclivities it does it doesn't mean
that I have given an invitation I mean
that why should why should you think so
I am saying that I have my preferences
maybe I like blondes maybe I like
colored women that's a preference it
doesn't mean that I have to say that oh
it's not alright to do it otherwise I
mean you have to think through and your
initial reaction that I don't like this
this is disgusting well it's disgusting
with amputation and that's actually a
more serious case than having sex
voluntarily with another person of the
same gender actually so here we have
cultural ideas and that is the important
point how do these things change they
change because we recognize greater and
greater freedom for the individual as
long as the activities of the individual
does not harm physically or
psychologically
other people you say the same with
animals was that the same answer well as
long as you're not hurting the animals
I'm also in favor of animal rights and
again I mean excuse me for going over
time but since you are adding to the
question here they that the question
here has I mean you can argue based on
principle but you can also argue as mr.
Hobart your job is done based on
empirical realities and then the
question becomes how how many people
does this involve what is the problem
here how large is the problem why should
we have laws against something that I
mean a very small minority and I would
like to see the statistics on how many
Norwegians are traveling to Denmark to
have sex with animals and what animals
by the way I mean this becomes sort of
absurd discussion thank you so I will
take one question to Mohammed ajob this
actually it feels like it's a follow-up
question the individual is asking how
does Islam regard these kinds of matters
sexual relationships with the same
gender and with animals and why do you
believe that that that your moral views
are correct first of all I find it quite
interesting that you find amputation of
hands disgusting but when we're talking
about having sex with dogs and cats and
horses this is not something that maybe
makes you feel disgusted and frankly
this shows you how much liberalism and
human rights are creatures of convention
they are subjective they are baseless
they're just basically what white people
sorry to say what why people find ok
what white people find tasty or for the
sensibilities of the white people that's
what
sorry to say that is liberalism in a
nutshell since it white man's not even
woman for the most part white man's
sensibilities subjective preferences
yeah it's okay for a brother and sister
to have sex but cutting the hand of the
thief I mean who who's made this the
parameters the correct parameters for us
it's a straightforward thing and when I
say white man I'm not meaning that the
rug rhetorically I'm meaning that quite
physically in the sense that the 1948
convention of human rights the ones who
had the ha the biggest say in that were
American white men because America
emerges as a superpower and it was in
charge of those particular institutions
and still is disproportionately
considering the size of China and Russia
by the way and there's lots of
literature on that I'm sure he's aware
so when we say the New World Order and
the white man is in control of the
basically the Preferences that we'd the
rest of the world we should be shaped in
the image and the mold of the white man
post enlightenment experience this is
the reality so you can have sex with the
dog potentially right he didn't want to
really say it you can have sex with your
mum and your dad sorry children I here
or your brother or your sister can have
enjoy your time freedom but you know
this thing about cutting the hand I
don't know about that it's disgusting oh
he's giving us the I mean to be honest
it's like I eat this I drink that it's
all a matter of taste now it's become
bit ridiculous cut force your tastes on
me I like Somali food you might like
Viking food you might like Norwegian I
don't know what they eat him you can't
tell me you have to eat the sausage and
this egg and I don't find that nice we
say the Murat J or the one who finally
determines which is acceptable moral
recourse and what is not acceptable to
answer the question is allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala is God Almighty and we have
good reason to believe God's exists God
exists we have good reason to believe
the Prophet Muhammad it is is the actual
final prophet he gives evidence is for
that and so divine command theory would
suggest that whatever comes from this is
eternally true which by the way can
adjust in terms of time and place but
that's part
the eternally true mechanism and that's
how we live our lives sexual matters
financial matters and so on and so forth
like I said if you want guidance you
have to seek guidance from the one who
knows well guidance which we believe is
God thank you I believe you have a
question from the microphone to the
doctor doula yes okay good I have many
questions actually I'll just make it
short
first of all question one is liberalism
changing with time I think you've kind
of answered it but I want to have a
fully answer because the past 400 years
today and then another 400 years from
now there's gonna come out of the person
like you who's gonna set different
things so he's there changing another
atheism isn't that a form of belief as
well you have some form of text or
believe you're holding on to third which
country we contact too many questions
because you only have three minutes to
answer I'm making sure that you talk
about homosexuality when it comes to
human anatomy human anatomy is not
created the way the homosexuals things I
work as a doctor and I see more cases
related to homosexuality diseases then
cousin women were married will come
there for their reasons the human
anatomy is not created the way the
homosexuality works no matter how you
try to define it change and you try to
make their human rights that they
deserve the human rights their Anatomy
is not made the correct way so evolution
no matter how much evolution you put
into it it's not gonna change so in in
terms of you talk about being good in
the society and making decided well good
for the people you're making everything
wrong for the the kids who are coming
after us they're gonna have more
diseases because of homosexuality I've
never seen any diseases we're cousins
and were married and they come because
of they have intercourse any other
reasons there are more diseases related
to homosexuality how can we change that
with time thank you yes thank you
liberalism is in continuous development
and I really hope that someone will come
with a good answer
in 400 years that differs from mine
today if not then the world had
stagnated so of course that is the whole
point liberalism or the defense of human
rights political philosophy develops
over time because it's a continuous
dialogue with history and the current
situation that is why philosophy is a
continuous process especially when we
are talking about morality ethics and
political organization the future will
be so different that to say now what it
should be like in 200 and 400 years is
absurd that's preposterous that that
would be like taking the position of God
and besides we have agreed here that
Islam and Islamic interpretations also
change over time
atheism is not a life stance not a
religion in itself it is a position on
certain aspects of reality you can have
good arguments you can have poor
arguments for atheism there are many of
them around my position is that I cannot
find contrary to mr. hijab good reasons
for believing in God I find all those
stories contradictory self contradictory
they don't make sense to me I recognize
that it makes sense to others so for
them you can believe whatever you want
of course you have the right to believe
what you want
homosexuality well if doctors if medical
science now and in the future discovers
problems with it well again we have we
are allowed to do a lot of things with
our bodies that some find stupid
discussed piercing for example tattooing
roof I don't like it
terrible women with holes in their ears
and rings and so on what's the point
I don't like it but it's there
right so if consenting adults have sex
with each other the same gender
it's up to them and no one should I mean
here it is interesting because the norms
of privacy in Islam are actually very
interesting what happens behind the
closed door is nobody's business so you
couldn't have sex with one of the same
kind it's nobody's business well to say
that it harms the people is a position
and that is an empirical statement and
that is something that can be
investigated empirically by the science
of Medicine and I say if you have
suggestions that it is harmful then you
can get give advice to those who
practice homosexuality and say you
should do it that way or not at all but
it's their business in the end thank you
eating is also harmful in my opinion
thank you
so we will take one question to Mohammed
a job that is actually very very
relevant now that you keep basing your
your arguments upon or bringing them
back to the existence of God how can you
actually prove that God exists this is
God the some of the proofs for medieval
proofs which are for example the
argument for contingency the Kalam
cosmological argument to find ash I
don't spend much time this is called
Kalam cosmological arguments the book so
it spends more time in Kalama
cosmological augment so if you want to
really know the answers question I'm not
gonna give you justice in three minutes
that that requires a long time so you
can get the book by it's wanted to
comment on a few things the gentleman
asked a very good question said 400
years someone else might come and say
something different and he admitted they
said hopefully that happens the thing is
if the white man has the edge on
hegemony on Hollywood and and and
political hegemony then really it will
be white people dictating how the rest
of us should live our lives and telling
us these are the correct kind of Rights
and these are not the correct kind of
Rights the truth is they have not done a
referendum on the rest of the world they
haven't gone to the African villages and
ask them what morality do you accept
what morality do you believe is true and
then predicated human rights based on
this kind of moral consensus of
for example so so could developing world
people's oriental people's and so on so
really what it's been in the
post-colonial world especially after
1945 World War two has been an agreement
among whites and that's what we've had
to be forced to kind of believe in or
that this course has been put has been
parameterised to that particular
narrative it's our these are the rights
which we consider the most important God
is not part of that it's a secular
discourse and therefore you have to
believe in it so for hundred years maybe
nowadays you might find burkas not nice
and bikinis are nice but maybe 400 years
you might like perky bikinis I don't
know it might be a white man but
basically whatever tickles the white
man's found fancy this is the problem
homosexuality is another thing you
talked homosexuality and bestiality and
so on the problem is he said you'd have
to see the dog or whatever animal it is
emotional visit dog is harmed or how can
a dog consent when they can't even speak
has he been the bark how's it gonna say
how a serious there I want to have sex
with you dog how to talks for yes and
one one part for how are you gonna know
I mean this is really this is the
absurdity of consent theory and
liberalism you know seriously I mean
where do we draw the line
you said stories contradict themselves
that's problematic because he said the
stories of the Koran contradicts itself
or in religion by neon last debate our
two minute twenty three I said you said
I don't spend much time reading the
Quran why should I
this is what you said so how do you know
the first contradict yourself you don't
even written the Koran properly and
moreover now you're enduring
contradictions when it comes to human
rights you enjoy the contradiction of
pluralism versus secularity
pluralism versus democracy individual
freedoms versus collective freedoms your
enduring those contradictions and your
acknowledging those and in durations and
therefore you shouldn't really be
sanctimonious in your presentation thank
you you were referring to me or to the
one who asked the question do you yeah
well I have not
about the Quran today you are not
reading the Quran with houses our
2-minute 23 I just I like to be
particular about those he said I don't
spend much time reading the Quran I know
I don't think I mentioned the quran at
all but we can go and find out I said
that stories about God yeah I find ok a
contradictory okay and that goes for the
Christian God and Hindu gods and so on
and so forth I don't find them
convincing ok so we have a question to
dr. lash from the other side I would ask
large cooler about one thing is the
cruel yeah it is cruel but one thing in
the television story now and I am
stealing from somebody who I have been
working from getting a television star
all the life I can go and steal another
place I'm not sure that I understood the
question is it good televisions thought
after I try to see from television
television ok yeah that that is the that
is the individual individual prevention
and in a quite physical way you try to
prevent the thief from stealing again by
making it physically impossible for for
him well you have arguments for that you
have had arguments for that in the in
the West in Europe that we need to be
strict
we had torture of traitors of Thieves
we had the burning of witches etc
etcetera to scare people
all of this was cruel and inhumane part
of the problem is that
you even can convict people execute
people for wrong reasons they actually
turn out to be innocent the whole idea
of modern penology the theories of
punishment is that we rehabilitate their
criminal
we condemn and punish the crime and we
rehabilitate the criminal and when we
are talking about the prevalence of
crime in the UK and in the States as mr.
hijab referred to I could inform him
that the Norwegian system far from being
perfect it is considered by many too
lenient but we have probably the lowest
recurrence rate in the world when it
comes to reoffending so actually a
humane system of punishment and
rehabilitation is better when it comes
to reducing crime than those with
serious with serious punishments and you
have the story from the Sudan when when
the Islamic Front introduced the sorry
after military coos there they started
with the the huddled punishments and the
story is that when they were chopping
off the hands of thieves in public with
huge crowds the pickpockets had a field
day so much for prevention thank you
do we have a question to mr. Ahuja yes
we have a quote not do he have a
question for Mohammed a job yes we have
a question tomorrow's a job great
question let me answer that question and
then move on to something I just wanted
to make a point on some of the comments
that were made
so we believe in Sharia consequentialism
yeah so something which is Hallel in one
place can be Haram in another and the
Quran says women at ography mussels
invite imagine if only it fella Geena
Holly so for example if you have to eat
pork in a certain time period if you're
if you're poor if you're forced to it
you can do it so this is where else will
comes in actually they take these
principles to do a soul so if you're
like a memory chef I said Colombo it
doesn't have to share how it does have
to share out the Kalama if the situation
becomes more constricted the Sharia
becomes more flexible and if the fear
becomes more flexible situation becomes
more constrict therefore yes there there
can be things which are completely Haram
like even saying Kelly met cover saying
words of court forget about Adam and
Eve's
children having intercourse which we we
don't have a problem with in that
context the same thing we don't have a
problem with someone making is can he
met Cofer in that context because their
maternal so where is the Aurora a dollar
ought to be her Novgorod as the spider
of the or the principle of a soul says
if there's if there's a if there's a
need for him and this absolute necessity
for the continuation of human race then
that becomes permissible and it's a
different context so to go so this idea
of a rigid Islam I totally agree with
Law School a people who believe in that
kind of rigid Islam will be able will
find it very difficult to navigate
themselves in the modern world just to
mention a point now because I have some
on barbarity or cruelty equals falsity
which is again cutting the hand of the
thief is cruel is an emotional argument
that's what that is I can make an
emotional argument as well I'll show you
for example in Islam we believe in
Turkish ass yeah so we believe it's
something I for an eye and an eye for I
doesn't make the whole world go blind it
makes it monocular because if someone
has one eye you see the other eye left
his ideas is false actually false
reasoning a bad logic but the point is
if you have a small daughter I'll make
an emotional argument yeah you have a
young daughter three years old a bad man
in East London where I'm not based but
I'm based in London walking around they
throw acid around like you know proper
acid yeah if you have a young daughter
and someone throws acid on her that
person gets a suspended sentence of five
years six years in prison ten years do
you think that's fair
I think majority of people from an
emotional perspective will say no and
this is an emotional argument say
actually the father should take acid and
put on that man as well let him live
with the consequences similar to that
which he inflicted on someone else and a
lot of people emotionally will accept
that kind of argument if you ask me to
prove it on first principles I won't be
able to I can prove it on divine command
theory but I can't prove it on first
principles that's the point I'm making
is subjective unless you have some kind
of anchorage and that is the point I'm
making if you want to make him emotional
arguments I can make emotional arguments
all day make you all angry talk about
pedophilia raping babies and so on they
should be killed and most of you will
agree with me but what I'm saying is we
can't prove those things from first
principles unless you have moral
objective Anchorage thank you we have a
question to dr. Lodge the sister is
wearing a niqab and she's mentioning
that dr. nasch he claims to be defending
the human rights and in the in in the
specific articles of Human Rights it is
constituted that everyone has the right
to education but dr. large he feels
disgusted that she is wearing a hijab or
sorry a niqab and he would not support
her right to education that's summarized
version opening
I'm not disgusted by much not any carbs
either but any cob prevents an open free
and equal dialogue and communication the
right to education is not absolute you
need grades you need to have qualified
we need qualifications in order to enter
higher education so there is a
meritocratic system here where you have
to have earned it through achieving
competence qualifications not wanting to
show your face to other people means
that you have said no to a lot of things
I mentioned piercing earlier if you are
wearing a lot of piercing including or
not even a lot of piercing but including
holes in your ears you have to remove
that if you are going to be a nurse or a
doctor in the Norwegian healthcare
system why not because it directly
immediately harms other people because
but because there are good reasons
medical hygienic reasons for that so if
you are choosing the profession of
Medicine you have to follow the rules of
that profession how to behave in a
responsible hygienic manner if you
choose to enter an academic institution
you should abide by the rules of that
institution and those rules are openness
equality trust etc and when you hide
your face behind any cop behind big
sunglasses or you wear a crash helmet we
do we see you down you are saying I
don't want to talk to you on an equal
footing so next time please address me
on the phone thank you okay so I've been
informed that at the time for the
question and answer session has been you
want to take one more question each okay
so let's take one more question is by
the request of the speakers so can we
have a question for
I'm in a job do we have a question from
the audience first and foremost because
the argot said we don't need to
liberalize Islam because we don't have a
proof that liberalism is true but if we
assume that liberalism is true is there
any part of Islam that happened to be
liberal last that last bit can you say
that if is there any part of this lambda
V was the word you said to summarize if
if we assume the premise that liberalism
is true are there any parts of Islam
that needs the liberal to needs to be
liberalized yeah well obviously if
liberalism is true everything this is
neutralized doesn't it because if that's
that's the point but we have to first
find out what liberalism are we talking
about we're talking about utilitarian
liberalism utilitarian consequentialist
liberalism what we're talking about a
hedonistic won a contract Aryan won a
non-contract Aryan won one that's based
on virtue ethics ethics a social
liberalism of political liberalism a
fiscal liberalism whose conception of
liberalism in what place what time so
first we have to discuss which
liberalism and then we have to discuss
if it was true that's something else
just just to make a comment on the niqab
issue so just to finalize the question
if obviously if liberalism is true then
we'd have to liberalize everything but
the point is that's not been proven
today with the admission of my
interlocutor to his credit and now
having said that the point of the club I
just wanted to mention that this was an
interesting discussion because in
Britain I'm not sure in no way if you
have any blind judges have you got any
blind judges in Britain we had a blind
judge in a place called Tower Hamlets in
London which means that judge you cannot
see and the main reason I see for those
advocates against niqab is that they say
well you can't see their facial
expressions right so that blocks
barriers to communication but if that's
the case in the same way as you would
need to ban any pub in a public space
then you'd have to say to blind people
that they shouldn't moderate certain
things including of course judiciary
because they wouldn't be able to see
people's facial expressions so all of
the
carry all of their judgments are
actually miscarriages of just justice if
seeing the face is so important you
should ban blind people from being
judges because actually that would mean
that everything that they're seeing is
not the full picture well of course this
is something you could have to be not
only with the judiciary but in many
other professions where it would be
deemed of course that such facial
expression is of paramount importance so
the the arguments will necessitate if
we're being consistent and if we from a
liberal perspective give equal privilege
to religious discrimination vis a vie
disability discrimination then we would
have to say that wherever there is a ban
on the pub because of communication or
the ILA with a positive reasoning is
communication problems then there should
be a ban on blind people being
communicators judges or otherwise
arbitrators in those settings as well if
you don't give those two things equal
ratings and you give disabled people
higher privilege then that is arbitrary
and arbitrariness is against liberalism
and there's no reason for it so I would
suggest that large schooling because
he's an intelligent man and a man who I
admire for his consistency on some
stances frankly to revise his position
on that based on his own principles
because I do think if he thinks about it
from those angles he may well change his
position she's like I'm not him
thank you
did we start with the first question to
dr. lush or to dr. Mohamed Merah job
okay so we have one last question for
dr. Kula so microphone please first
first of all I just want to say to you
never say woman called me on my phone
because she's never gonna do that so you
just if she's wearing nip-ups oh that's
hopeless yeah and my question is I just
got in Norwegian I will try to translate
it in English Shama so how would you
define the freedom of religion for
children like small kids because the
parents they just want to learn their
children what they think is good for
them yeah the same does Muslims as well
but in West whatever the non-muslims
does they it's like his freedom but if
like here in Norway we got like choosing
a boyfriend or girlfriend or dancing in
pairs and yeah I'm going to discos and
such things but if a Muslim for a father
or mother just avoids their children not
to do such things then their children
are oppressed so how would you define
like the freedom of religion for
children thank you thank you it's an
interesting and difficult question
because according to international human
rights law the legally binding
conventions parents are the ones who are
responsible for their children's
religious upbringing so they have a
right to to impart their religious
beliefs to children and I defend that
right because I cannot see anyone else
who should do it so this is a moral
argument and not a legal argument it is
and
it's an appeal not only to Muslim
parents but to all parents to give
children freedom to explore to
investigate to find out what they want
to believe in and one of the things that
parents should do is to give them that
the freedom to opt out of the religion
of parents by not telling them that if
you change your religion we're not going
to talk to you anymore
furthermore parents should not make
irreversible physical changes to their
children as a mark of their religious
belonging circumcision of men boys
should stop if a man wants to be
circumcised as a sign of his belonging
to a given religion he can do so after
he has become mature 18 years of age and
this goes of course
for female genital mutilation totally
unacceptable in order to make a
religious cultural identity statement
here children should have freedom to
decide if they want to cut off the whole
thing after they are have become 18 but
parents should not make that
irreversible decision for their children
and they should give them a liberal
meaning non strict upbringing so that
they can explore various life stances
religions etc that's what I mean but
about giving freedom of religion to
children but and this is because it is a
responsibility to parents to what is the
the good English world they are for
vaulted they are the keepers of their
children's safety and moral upbringing
and that is a big responsibility and it
has to be carried out in a very good way
so it's wrong but if they no no no no no
I'm welcome there are different ways of
teaching children religion you can say
this is what we believe but you are free
to choose or you can say this is what we
believe and this is what you are going
to believe and if you say otherwise we
are going to kill you
that's the difference you see the point
[Music]
sorry you need to use the microphone I
don't know if it's the acoustics of this
room or my age but I simply cannot hear
even if I've got the new hearing aid the
news of the adults should do then he
should decide and do circumcision so
what you said right again circumcision
yesterday yep that you said a person
should be adult and then he should
decide and then do it exactly have you
ever seen don't do it circumcision no
I've seen it
do you know which prognosis will be bad
a kid on the 5 years old
performing circumcision adult who is
well developed Oh 18 having some
decision who would have a backward
notice any good surgeon who is
performing what till you answer that
maybe you could tell me when you think
about that is irrelevant the question
here because you might not make it clean
no no no no no a person should be a dog
and then exhibition yet from science
it's proven that a kid has a better
prognosis and a better result of
services I I don't matter how much you
say that it's just a wider bundle I
don't care the point here is see there
you go that's the point
no I'm all give you enough to you
that point II understand I'm no I'm not
I'm not discussing medicine I'm
discussing right now drawing a claim
like that of course I can
what I'm saying is that if you
circumcised a child you have introduced
that child to a certain culture and
religion without wait let me speak
without the consent of the child that is
taking away from the child a possibility
to choose later on if you as an adult
decide to do something and it is very
scary because now move out this can have
complications that is your choice but
because it is more difficult when you
are older you cannot impose it on the
child when the child cannot consent
[Music]
gnosis is irrelevant gnosis a moral
question or fear is not an empirical
medical one second one second one second
so just a quick quick so if they do this
in America for medical reasons not being
Muslims then that would be okay you know
why not the arguments for medical
benefits when targeting drugs or
medicines etc the argument for origin
let me answer don't interrupt the
argument for medical advantages of a
child circumcision of of babies or
children are weak and nevertheless they
are irrelevant from a moral perspective
because it is the person who has the
right to decide on these things we are
talking about something that is
irreversible
an injection oxygen vaccine and so on
they are not irreversible and parents
usually it goes with an operation the
child has an illness they bring into the
hospital of
then the parents decides based on
medical advice on what is best for the
child
he/she needs an operation to get rid of
the appendix that has become infected
that is not a problem that is taking
care of a life that is saving life that
is protecting life you are not
protecting life by cutting off part of
the penis okay let's stop the penis talk
non go on so this went on quite a bit
long and we are getting more requests
that people want to ask their questions
and their kind of really any we're gonna
give one more question head and I have
to take one more for good as well to
make it fair understood that we cannot
approve liberalism that's why we cannot
go further with this discussion about
liberalism but what about if we say can
Islam or part of Islam be modernized can
we modernize Islam and the Methuselah
and philosophers did they modernize
Islam at that time mhm thank you
so theories of modernization usually
revolve around post enlightenment
thought processes and usually the
dominant ethic being referred to either
directly or indirectly is liberalism
democracy individualism and those things
as it's usually a Eurocentric basically
definition of modernization however just
to kind of point something out which is
very important two things actually which
I've been hearing just trying to listen
to the interchange between dr. gulam and
the audience members so the the point of
not introducing them to a certain
culture and religion goes against human
rights actually because one of the human
rights is right to education 0.3 says
parents have a prior right to choose the
kind of education that shall be given to
their child and this goes to the heart
of a problem which we were facing in
Birmingham in the United Kingdom which
is do does the school have the right to
young children for example certain
sexual things or do the parents have the
right the one of the best arguments from
their own paradigm and I'm saying from
their own paradigm to make it very clear
but we don't disagree with this that a
parent should have a right to to give
education to their child now you can't
limit the variables and say you can have
a right to give education but it can't
be an Islamic one because that will go
against the two points of liberalism
consent and reciprocity and goes against
this human right actually so from a
human rights perspective from a liberal
perspective you can't actually maintain
that I'm allowed to teach my child to be
an agnostic atheist liberal feminist but
this person from Somalia from
Afghanistan from Pakistan he doesn't
have their right to give them their
moral ethic that's actually a kind of
totalitarianism it's movies veering in
the in the direction of totalitarianism
which I'm sure is against but it's quite
odd that I heard that argument being
made moreover FGM is usually associated
with the Middle East and Africa
but that's because there's been a
problem convention with FGM FGM is
practiced most by Western women because
the way that a whu-oh defines FGM
includes things like piercings which we
know now dr. Guha is against in the
vagina and labiaplasty which are
construction surgeries to basically
sorry to be explicit thin the lips of
the vagina for a woman which is usually
done for cosmetic reasons the NHS which
is the National Health Service in UK
actually gives guidance to women on how
to do this so the point is there is and
this is becoming quite prominent in the
literature now FGM depending on how you
actually define it could be said to be
an epidemic in the Western world but
it's always looking at the Muslims or
the Arabs or the Africans with a view to
make them a subject of investigation and
peculiarities that makes them an
Orientalist point for liberal critique
which i think is hypocritical in all its
forms thank you we will take the last
question to dr. doula is there anyone
okay wait let me see the too many hands
did now this will be the last one
unfortunately when you say remember you
say uno rises human rights it's not the
definition but in social science as we
learn the definition is what the most
important thing when you want to have a
good theory and if you say in the social
science from Karl Marx and Max Weber to
did to this day with the body all they
have tried to do is redefinition the
culture for example so I feel I finally
problematic when he says we don't need
to defy the definition the human rights
but I can understand you if we say it's
a a priori but then you say later that
in the 70s that sexual rice wasn't there
and that human rights will develop and
that goes against a priori as we know
that count when he said that April you
have some principles and ice cannot
change over time so if human rights is
not a priori so how can you argument for
human rights with a definition please
thank you
of course you have to define human
rights I what I have said is that you
cannot prove them you cannot give a
scientific proof of human rights
you can argue to justify them but of
course you have to define them and you
can basically say that we have three
major human rights is the right to life
their right to Liberty and right - well
fair well being and what we find in the
different conventions are concrete
decisions of those three major types of
human rights now that is by itself a
definition of them and
or sometimes legally binding and then
you can extend them and give them moral
value and so on and they change as I
said because you can expand them and
give more rights emphasize certain
rights and so on so I'm not against the
attempting to define in a serious and
meaningful way human rights on the
contrary but I am saying that you cannot
give a mathematical proof you can give
good justifications for human rights I
thank you because if you say like when
in the social science when you don't
prove a thing
you put it in the a priori category but
as you say in the principles the human
rights when you as you talk about them
they don't fit with the principles of a
period so even for core with the
postmodernist
they have some principles so I'm looking
to understand cuz I want to understand I
want to understand how I can prove human
rights and fight for human rights with
reason so if I cannot put in the a
priori category and I have no principles
as the postmodernist so how can I find
principles to understand cuz I have to
understand as a human being as a
rational thank you you have one minute
to answer that question yeah there are
elements of a priori Ness here when we
are talking about human Worth and human
dignity as debate well human Worth and
human dignity is what is protected by
human rights human rights is a
consequence of human beings having human
Worth and human dignity and that is a
metaphysical position I agree it is
something that you can argue for you can
try to give it it's some sort of
empirical reference by saying that
social reality is normative we are all
living in a world where we are following
rules and we do so instinctively
actually so in that sense there is a in
a certain a priori Ness and also
actually
an empirical reference here but it is
but I would not claim to prove human
rights I I wouldn't this is an ongoing
philosophical discussion where human
rights have good arguments based on many
different positions something I will
come back to in the summation thank you
so we will end the question and answer
session with that and dr. last you will
have five minutes to give you final
earmarks and mohammadi job you will have
also five minutes to give your final
remarks then I will conclude the session
and after that everyone stay seated we
have a big surprise okay thank you
okay okay first of all we are not
talking about taste when we are talking
about cruelty we are talking about not
our subjective experience of taste we
are talking about something that has to
do with right and wrong we're not
talking about false or true false and
true relates to the empirical work it is
true that the Earth revolves around the
Sun it is not right or wrong it's not
right or wrong
right or wrong relates to it's not true
to say that it is wrong to kill someone
that's not true it is wrong to kill
someone the fact that the world is
divided into different spheres and where
we have an empirical sphere describing
reality telling us how things are is
different from morality law and politics
where we are talking about how things
should be that is something that has to
do with with norms norms is something
that we can discuss human rights are
norms they also represent
values those values are important
because they are there to defend to
protect human worth and human dignity
and therefore human rights have good
reasons they have been given by
theologians Muslim theologians Christian
theologians they have be given by
philosophers they have been given by
legal scholars political scientists
politicians have all given good reasons
for human rights and those reasons have
been accepted they have been accepted by
a majority of Representatives of the
people of the earth it is not true when
mr. hijab says that they were a Western
invention they have a long history in
the West but just as little as there is
a Western mathematics Western Natural
Science Western physics Western
chemistry there are no Western human
rights they are universal when they were
developed in order to be put on paper
made into a declaration that was an
intercultural process where
representatives of the Muslim world of
the Confucian world of the atheist world
as well as the Christian world took part
there was an argument we need God here
we need God to guarantee human dignity
and human Worth and then you would think
it was the atheist communist who said no
we don't go for God but it wasn't it was
the Confucians the Chinese they said
we're confusions we don't believe in God
and then the committee who drafted the
human rights declaration realized that
we can agree on the human rights but we
don't have to agree on the reason our
own justification for human rights
therefore you can have your is
justification for human rights as many
Muslims scholars legal scholars
philosophers have or you can have my
rationalist arguments in favor you can
have Christian arguments you can heal
Hindu and Buddhist arguments human
rights are not carved in stone they are
developing as we use our reason in order
to understand and improve the world we
are living in in order to prove improve
the protection of each and every one of
us and so far they have done a good job
it does not mean that they are being
respected universally even though they
are universally applicable even though
they have universal pretensions they are
not respected universally that's why
fighting for human rights including
freedom of expression and the right to
blaspheme including freedom of religion
also the right to change your religion
and I'm not sure that mr. hijab knows
but in dialog between Christians and
Muslims in Norway it was actually agreed
that the right to change your religion
is a basic human rights which should be
respected by Muslims without
repercussions for members of
congregations mosques or families who
changed their religion the final point
education has to do with becoming a good
citizen a functioning citizen that's why
in general parents can take care of that
right but sometimes they don't do it in
a good way that's why we have Child
Services barnevernet
that's why we can also make demands on
the content of education for children so
that they will function in a good way in
a democratic society thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
thank you dr. lush for your final
remarks so I would request Muhammad
hijab to give his final remarks as well
well just to comment on some of the
things that were said in the final part
of that summary is that it was an
intercultural process deciding human
rights was the intercultural process it
was an intercultural process to some
degree but one that the Western elites
presided over especially after World War
Two this is well known history I mean
there was a bipolar system of
international relations where Soviet
Union and America became the two
dominant forces and of course America
controlled the international
organizations including of course the UN
of course he was talking about Chinese
he refers to them as a confusion world I
would put him that probably the liberal
world is the one that's confused but
Chinese have a whole different set of
moral injunctions if you go to South
China sometimes you might see some
restaurant of people eating dogs for
example although Oba I mean they're not
making arguments to have sex with them
it's still completely different in terms
of the prioritization of Rights and we
don't see the world shape shaped in
Chinese or Russian rights images my
opponent today has been asked three
questions to prove liberalism / human
rights to prove the presuppositions of
those things including freedom equality
etc and then also to consider admit that
within liberal systems you can have
punitive laws corporal punishments
racism colonialism etc and to my
surprise he actually agrees with me on
all three of those points which is I
think a very good way to end a debate
where the two people agree on some of
the main issues were in regards to moral
theory so I want to thank my opponent
for coming today and putting up with my
hostile approach to debating which has
become a hallmark of my
my interchanges with people and I also
want to thank my family because they had
to put up with me as well preparing for
the debates like this but also preparing
for research material that I had to do
by going back to something about family
and I've kind of alluded to this before
within my discussion that aslam puts
community rights over individual rights
for the most part and put God's rights
above all of that that is the
prioritization of its land it's a
different completely different
prioritization to human rights
we don't disregard or deny some of those
30 articles of even rights in fact agree
with a lot of them if not I would say
most of them frankly I mean might come
as a surprise but we would just disagree
with the way in which their phrasing
prioritized we would disagree in the way
in which rights are poor of
responsibilities the Islamic discourse
it it puts more emphasis on
responsibilities in rights because if
everyone is selfish nothing will get
done at the end of the day if everyone's
thinking about what they owed then there
will not be reciprocity in a communal
space and so therefore membership or
fraternity to a community is prioritized
over individual interests and that is
something we say it comes from divine
command theory but also helps for the
welfare of human beings across time
actually this is something which many
liberal scholars I would call them
liberal maybe they wouldn't call
themselves liberal would actually agree
with me on they referred to as
communitarians
like Michael Sandel in his book theories
of Justice they actually say the
community spirit you're born into
membership in family and so on and
historical lineage and therefore you
should prioritize communal arrangements
before and above individual ones or a is
the case now going back to one thing
that we did disagree upon which was
definitions in this debate I think that
my opponent did employ a fallacy of
equivocation for example of someone in
front of me now had a heart attack may
be one of the Liberals when he saw my
first presentations and when I joke and
had a stroke and then maybe the doctor I
say is there a doctor the doctor
there comes and actually doctor gula
comes up and tries to I said I want a
doctor but in this case I meant a
medical doctor not a professor right so
it's using a word in a completely
different way in order to avoid a
particular argument so what I was using
the word liberalised as I've proven in
popular usage this means in reference to
political philosophy in particular
liberalism but he did indeed disengaged
from that because he knew the moment we
scrutinize liberal philosophy is the
moment that would be the end of the
debate however to end this debate on a
good note what I would say is that
instead of reform we should both and we
I think we do agree that there should be
reconciliation between Muslims
traditionalists Muslims and liberals and
both of us need to be as flexible as
possible in facilitating such
reconciliation as the Quran says Lacombe
Deen accumulating you have your way and
we have our way but we will build
bridges and we thank you for all the
good work you do so everyone a round of
applause for our schooling it has been a
great honour for me today
to hold to host this great debate
between Muhammad Hodja and large gula
and I asked Lost Planet Allah to accept
this efforts of ours and put barakah in
this and make us and give us more
opportunities to arrange debates like
this again say I mean and we ask allah
subhanaw taala
to guide all of us to the right path dr.
nasch muhammad hijab and all of us we
all need the guidance of allah say yeah
I mean so with that I thank our two
participants dr. Lodge and Mohammad
hijab and I will conclude this session
by this and for those who are watching
online and all of you as well as I
mentioned early earlier or in the
beginning of the program that we are
working on a project to establish a
Masjid and a Dawa Center here in the ha
of Norway in Oslo in the capital of
Norway so please go into the website
save Amman calm to read more about this
project save Amman calm and you will
find the link in the description of this
video and please participate with your
participation as much as you can thank
you so much the pod how's Amanda not
good ok it's not good is it really that
bad I'm really afraid of this is there
anything we could do to save Iman yes
Iman is dying but we can save Iman with
your donation please watch until the end
and give for the sake of Allah and he is
Subhan Allah Tala we'll give you up to
700 times in return and build for you a
house in general I am Fahad Qureshi and
I'm chairman of the Islamic Network
Islam net one of the most influential
Islamic organizations in my nation I was
born and raised in a European country
called Norway in search of a better life
my parents migrated to Norway in the 70s
what they didn't realize was that a man
may not be able to survive this journey
the population of Norway is around 5.3
million people with Muslims making up
200,000 of that population the number of
Muslim names is increasing but the
number of Muslims with Iman is
decreasing in other words a man is dying
in the hearts of our youth today it's
laminate has been for the last 10 years
working non-stop
and developing keed our projects to
maintain the Muslim identity for our
next generation so we are making a
change I was a non Muslim with no
purpose in life but Allah guided me and
Islam that gave me a platform to spread
Islam in
country slam net has given me an
opportunity not only to learn is am but
also to give Dawa and invite all the
children to Islam I can't express how
grateful I am for having Islam that in
my life through our projects we are
combating Islamophobia inviting
non-muslims to Islam giving thar beer to
the youth guiding non practicing Muslims
back to Allah giving support to reverts
fighting extremism and empowering the
Muslim community to get involved in Dawa
we have been operating from a small
office that no longer can cater for our
needs we need to establish a Masjid with
a dower and community center that can
host Islamic events and exhibitions have
a youth center and offices where we can
have full time to add expanding the Dawa
and Serbia programs so we can bring up a
generation of youth aspiring to make the
word of Allah the highest and that is
absolutely brilliant we have to do this
brothers and sisters donate generously
and help us to establish it is Masjid
and Dara centre don't forget to make
duaa and share this video on all your
social media platforms so everyone can
benefit from this amazing project we are
not going to let a man die
[Music]